NMRA SO WHY DON'T WE GET STARTED
HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING OF THE JOINT WAS SORT OF
AUDIT COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS THE
STATE THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH.
OF THIS AFTERNOON WILL BE
FOCUSING ON.
HEARING FROM THE STATE AUDITOR
EARNED HER A REPORT ON.
HER AYE AUDIT ENTITLED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT THE STATE
COULD BETTER ENSURE THE
EFFECTIVE USE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING.
I WANT ONE I THINK A CENTER
BELL.
AND THE EIGHT OTHER CENTERS IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO WERE THE
REQUEST YEARS.
OF THIS AUDIT.
WE ARE EXPECTING CEREBELLUM BE
JOINING US SOON.
ARE WE WILL ALSO.
AB BE DISCUSSING THE CHANGES AND
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS IMPLEMENTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE AUDIT.
I. WE HAVE A LOT OF COMMITTEE
HEARINGS GOING ON NOW ENDS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT CENTER BELL HAS
HIS OWN TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
HEARING AT THREE THIRTY AND SO.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE A.
FULL AND AND HEALTHY A
DISCUSSION ON THIS IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND BE DONE BY BY THREE
THIRTY.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
FOCUSING ON THIS ISSUE FOR MANY
YEARS IN FACT OF THIS.
IS THE.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST AUDIT ON
THE SUBJECT MATTER THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE REQUESTED A PRIOR
AUDIT IN TWENTY TWELVE. ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT IN
THAT AUDIT WAS REQUESTED BY
THEN.
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM DARRELL
STEINBERG.
THERE ON A REPORT THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON TODAY LOOKS AT THE
FUNDING AND OVERSIGHT ASSOCIATED
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
AND THAT WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR IN TERMS OF THE
KEY FINDINGS OF THE I. I JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN NOW. HAVE
A FRUITFUL AND.
CONCISE HEARING TODAY.
I'M ASKING THAT THE PANELS KEEP
THE PRESENTATIONS.
TO BE FOLLOWING TIME
ALLOCATIONS.
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION.
THEN UP TO TEN MINUTES FOR EACH
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. รณ AS WELL
AS I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A.
COUNTY SUPER SECOND COUNTY
SUPERVISOR PATRICK KENNEDY.
WHO'S ALSO BEEN ADDED TO.
THE SECOND PANEL.
AND THE FOLLOWING THAT PANEL.
FOLLOWING EACH PANEL MEMBERS
WILL HAVE UP TO TWENTY MINUTES
FOR QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS.
I THINK THAT IS IT AND SO I'D
LIKE TO INVITE UP OUR STATE
AUBURN HER TEAM TO. MAKE THE
FIRST PRESENTATION ON THE
OVERVIEW OF THE AUDIT FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS MY NAME'S ELAINE HOWELL
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
WITH ME TO MY RIGHT IS JOHN
BEYER JOHN WAS THE AUDIT MANAGER
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT AND
TO MY LEFT IS RALPH WHEN MISTER
FLYNN WAS THE TEAM LEADER
SUPERVISOR WORKING WITH STAFF.
ARE AT THE STATE AGENCIES AND WE
DID VISIT THREE LOCAL AGENCIES.
I WILL GO OVER THE ISSUES IN A
VERY HIGH LEVEL THAT I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MISTER FLYNN WHO
WILL GO INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICS ABOUT THE THREE KEY
ISSUES THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN THE
REPORT. AND THEN LAY OUT AGAIN
IN A VERY HIGH LEVEL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE BUYERS AVAILABLE WHEN WE GET
INTO THE QUEUE IN A.
ANNA AND WILL ASSIST IN
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS
MAY HAVE. SO FAR THIS AUDIT
REPORT AND AS YOU INDICATED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS ISSUED IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR I WAS
REQUESTED BY MULTIPLE SENATORS
LAST YEAR. APPROVED BY THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TOOK US ABOUT SIX OR
SEVEN MONTHS TO COMPLETE THE
WORK AND WE HAD THREE KEY ISSUE
AREAS.
THAT WE IDENTIFIED OR DISCUSS
IN THE AUDIT REPORT FIRST TWO
ARE RELATED TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE THE FIRST AREA
AGAIN MISTER FLYNN WILL GET INTO
SPECIFICS BUT IT'S REALLY
LOOKING AT THE FISCAL ASPECTS.
OF.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND
A LOOKING AT REVERSION PROCESS
LOOKING AT UNSPENT FUNDS
IDENTIFYING ON SPEND FUNDS A
LOOKING AT INTEREST THAT HAS
BEEN EARNED. AYE THE AMOUNTS IN
RESERVE.
AND CERTAINLY I ANY FUND
BALANCES THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
SO THAT FIRST KEY AREAS REALLY
LOOKING AT THE FISCAL. ASPECTS
OF THE OF THE AMOUNT HEALTH
SERVICES ACT AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT IS CURRENTLY OUT
THERE THAT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
SPENT.
THE SECOND AREA IS LOOKING AT
OVERSIGHT LOOKING AT WHAT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IS DOING TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE. OF CONDUCTING
AUDITS AND CERTAINLY FROM A
PROGRAM PERSPECTIVE TO IDENTIFY
THE POSITIVE IMPACT THAT HAS
HAPPENED OUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AS FAR AS OUTCOMES AND AND THE
UP POSITIVE. ALL ASPECTS OF THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
BY THIS ACT SO MISTER FLYNN WILL
GO INTO SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
REPORTS THAT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS SUPPOSED TO RECEIVE
FROM LOCALS. OUT WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AS FAR AS PROVIDING ANY
FISCAL OVERSIGHT AND CERTAINLY
PROGRAM OVERSIGHT. AND THEN THE
THIRD AREA IS THE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION.
AND WHAT IT'S PROCESSES ARE WITH
RESPECT TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OFF CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT SPECIFIC AREAS THEY
HAVE A VERY.
IMPORTANT ROLE WITH RESPECT TO
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS AND APPROVAL
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF THOSE
PROJECTS FOR LOCAL ENTITIES.
THEY ALSO LOOK AT.
SOME ANNUAL REPORTS THAT THEY
HAVE NOW REQUIRED LOCALS TO
SUBMIT THAT REQUIREMENT WAS
RECENT THEY REQUIRE THESE
REPORTS TO. A COMMON AS RECENTLY
AS DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR. WE
THINK THEY'VE DONE A GOOD JOB OF
THAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
SOME PROCESS IS NOW TO ANALYZE
THAT INFORMATION. OUGHT TO
DETERMINE WHAT BENEFITS ARE
AGAIN ARE OCCURRING OUT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND IN THE LAST YEAR
IS LOOKING AT TRIAGE GRANT THIS
IS. A LEGISLATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. APPROVED AND AND
HAS BEEN ENACTED IN THIS IS TO
PROVIDE EXPANSION OF SERVICES A
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH PERSONNEL. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN EMERGENCY ROOMS JAILS
HOMELESS SHELTERS AT SARAH SO
THE THREE KEY ISSUE AREAS TO AND
HEALTH CERTAIN HEALTH. CARE
SERVICES ONE OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION LET MISTER FLYNN STEP
THROUGH THOSE AND THEN HE CAN.
LAY OUT WHAT THE KEY OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE THAT WE HAD
BOTH FOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND THE OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
THANK YOU TO TELL A GOOD
AFTERNOON.
SHE CHAIRMAN IS RALPH ONE OF THE
AUDITOR WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND I WAS THE TEAM LEAD
ON THIS PROJECT.
.
AS WITH ALL INDICATE WE FOUND
TWO MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
HEALTHCARE SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND MONITORING OF THE EMERGENCY
PROGRAM. OF THE FIRST WAS
THE COUNTIES ARE SPENDING THE
MONEY EFFECTIVELY THE SECOND
REGARDING. OVERSIGHT ENSURING
THAT THE MONEY IS BEING SPENT
APPROPRIATELY.
SO THE FIRST KEY ISSUE
REGARDING.
WAS THAT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS NOT DEVELOP A PROCESS TO
RECOVER FUND UNSPENT ENERGY
FUNDS ARE SUBJECT TO A VERSION.
AS OF JUNE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT THERE WAS
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE MILLION THAT WOULD SUBJECT
TO REVERSION THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN REALLOCATED TO OTHER
COUNTIES. HAD HAD HEALTHCARE
SERVICES ESTABLISH A REVERSION
PROCESS.
ALTHOUGH THE LEGISLATURE MADE A
ONE TIME CHANGE IN ITS A LOT TO
THOUSAND. THAT ALLOW THESE
COUNTIES TO MEET TO KEEP THIS
REVERTED DOLLARS WE HAD CONCERNS
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
HAS BEEN SLOW TO ESTABLISH A
WRITTEN VERSION PROCESS.
.
HEALTHCARE SERVICES INDICATED OF
THAT IT NEEDED REGULATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT A REVERSION PROCESS.
FOR REVERSION AND FOR MANY
OTHER.
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAD.
AND OUR CONCERN WAS THAT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES HAVE BEEN IN
THIS ROLE OF OVERSIGHT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
BOTTOM THE TIDE.
ROUGHLY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUAL FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THESE REGULATIONS THAT STILL IS
NOT A INCLUDING THESE
REGULATIONS.
WE NEVER REALLY GOT A CLEAR
EXPLANATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
REGARDING WHY THESE DELAYS ARE
OCCURRING. HOWEVER DURING THE
REPORT. ARE DURING THE AUDIT
PROCESS THE FIRST INDICATED THAT
THESE REGULATIONS WE ESTABLISHED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THEN THEY WERE PUSHED OUT TO
JUNE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
FINALLY WHEN THE REPORT WAS
ISSUED. HEALTH CARE SERVICES
INDICATED THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
THESE REGULATIONS OUT UNTL.
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
THIS CONTINUE SLIDING OF THE
REGULATIONS GAVE US CONCERN AND
PAUSE AND. AS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WILL BE FOLLOWING UP WITH
AS THE REGULAR AT THE.
RECOMMENDATIONS COME IN.
.
ANOTHER AREA OF CONCERN THAT WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WAS THE LEVEL
OF AND WHICH IS A FUNDS OF THE
COUNTIES ARE HOLDING A RESERVE.
STATE LAW ALLOWS THE COUNTIES TO
MAINTAIN A PRUDENT RESERVE.
TO ENSURE THAT.
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES.
HOWEVER AS OF JUNE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE DON'T OF THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN HELD RESERVES
TOLLING FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH IS A RESERVE OF ROUGHLY
FORTY SEVEN PERCENT.
OF THESE PRE RESERVE DOLLARS ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO REVERSION AND
THEREFORE THESE DOLLARS CAN STAY
WITH THE COUNTIES.
EFFECTIVELY INDEFINITELY.
THE LAW DOES NOT SPECIFY A.
A LOOK UP APPROPRIATE LEVEL FOR
THE COUNTIES TO MAINTAIN FOR
PRETTY RESERVE.
AND DIE IN THE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS NOT ESTABLISHED
ONE.
BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF THE
TRENDS FOR.
AND WE SAY FUNDS OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS WE IDENTIFIED AS
APPROVING RESERVE LEVEL OF AT AT
BATS ARE THE HIGHEST THIRTY
THREE PERCENT.
FOR PRIOR YEAR BEAUTY SERVICES
VIOLENCE.
NOW HAD COUNTIES IMPLEMENTED A
RESERVE FUND OF THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. WE NOTED THAT.
THERE WOULD THEY WOULD HAVE
FREED UP. NEARLY A HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO PROMOTE
AND EXPAND METAL SERVICES AT THE
LOCALS.
.
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DISAGREED
WITH OUR FINDINGS AND BELIEVE
THAT A RANGE OF BETWEEN SIXTY
FOUR EIGHTY TWO PERCENT WOULD BE
PRUDENT.
WE DISAGREE WITH THAT AMOUNT AND
FIND THAT IT'S EXCESSIVE WOULD
JUST WILL.
INCREASE WOULD RESULT IN A
REDUCTION IN FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR RENTAL SERVICES ALLOW
ADDITIONAL FUNDS JUST GATHER
DUST.
.
FURTHER UNTIL OUR INQUIRY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND NOT
QUESTION.
A REASON FOR NEARLY TWO AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FUND BALANCE
IN ITS IMAGE SAY FUND.
AND WHETHER THE BALANCE
REPRESENT FUNDS DUE TO LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES OR WAS A
LONGSTANDING ACCOUNTING HERE.
AS A RESULT OF OUR ENQUIRIES
HEALTHCARE SERVICES IS NOT
WORKING WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO
DETERMINE. THE THE NATURE OF
THIS FUND AND. WHAT IT STANDS
FORM?
?
OUR RECOMMENDATION FOR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES FOCUS ON
FULFILLING WHAT IS FAILED TO DO
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMENDED
THAT BY JUNE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN HEALTHCARE SERVICES. UP
PROPOSED REGULATIONS FOR THE
COUNTIES.
GUIDANCE ON THE RIVERS ARE
PROCESS.
DESTRUCTIONS ON A HOW TO SPEND
INTEREST THEY EARN ON AVERAGE
THEY FUNDS.
ESTABLISH AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
FOR RESERVE. AND THESE
REGULATIONS WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH
A PROCESS TO WITHHOLD FRONT FROM
COUNTIES THAT FAILED TO SUBMIT
THEIR ANNUAL EXPENSE REPORTS.
A TIMELY.
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT BETTER OVERSEE
COUNTIES PUBLISHING OF
REGULATIONS IT WAS NECESSARY. A.
FOR FISCAL AUDIT PROCESS.
SO BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
ESTABLISHED A FISCAL AUDIT
PROCESS FOR IMAGES SAY.
HOWEVER IT TIED THIS TO ITS MEDI
CAL REVIEWERS. AND WE DETERMINED
THAT THESE MEDICAL REVIEWS ARE
NEARLY SEVENTY EIGHT YEARS IN
ARREARS.
SO THEY'RE LOOKING BACK AT
EVENTUALLY DOLLARS NEARLY SEVEN
TO EIGHT YEARS AGO W. W. THAT
PROVIDER CONTEMPORANEOUSLY
REVIEW OF HOW THE IMAGE THE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
WE ALSO WILL I THOUGHT THE BILL
THEY ALSO DISCUSSED
ESTABLISHING YOUR PROGRAM VIEW
REVIEW PROCESS.
AND THEY'VE INDICATED THAT THEY
WERE ESTABLISHED THAT.
SOON.
REGARD THE OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
WE FOUND THAT HAS BEEN MORE
PROACTIVE.
THERE FOR OVER A REPORTS
FINDINGS GENERALLY FOCUS ON THE
COMMISSION A FINISHING EFFORTS
THAT IT ALREADY IS. HAS UNDER
WAY.
FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE STRUGGLED SUSPEND
THEIR INNOVATION FUNDS HAD A
TIMELY MANNER. OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY WE'RE TORRENT AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ALTHOUGH SOME FREE VERSION.
NEARLY HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WAS AN
INNOVATION FUNDS.
IT'S REALLY REPRESENTING SIXTY
THREE PERCENT OF THE RIVER THE
FUNDS.
NOW THE COUNTIES HAVE INDICATED
THAT THERE HAVE STRUGGLING TO
DETERMINE WHAT ACT ACTUALLY IS
AN INNOVATIVE FUND THAT COULD
GET APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION.
AND THE COMMISSION INDICATED TO
US THAT WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES. OF
THAT THEY'RE DOING OUTREACH TO
THESE COUNTIES AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT WOULD REPRESENT AN
INNOVATIVE PROJECT AND TO HELP
THESE COUNTIES GET INNOVATIVE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE APPROVED.
AND EFFECTIVE AND MEET THE THE
REQUIREMENTS TO EXPAND A PROMOTE
INNOVATIVE AND NEW TECHNIQUES
TO.
FOR METAL SERVICES.
.
THE COMMISSION WAS AWARE OF THIS
AND THEREFORE WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THEY CONTINUE ON WITH THESE
EFFORTS.
I AM ALSO IS MICHELLE INDICATED
THE OVER THE COMMISSION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TRIAGE GRANTS.
AND WE SAW THAT THEY'RE DOING A
GOOD PROCESS OF ALLOCATING THE
GRANTS TO THE LOCALS. AND ALSO
ESTABLISHING AT A LOCAL LEVEL A
PROCESS TO EVALUATE IF THESE
TRIAGE GRANTS ARE MEETING THE
THE GOALS.
HOWEVER THEY HAVE NOT ESTABLISH
A STATE WIDE METRIC TO EVALUATE
WHETHER NOT. THESE GRANTS ARE
MEETING THEIR GOALS.
AND WE RECOMMENDED THAT THEY
ESTABLISH ONE AND THOSE ARE
COMMISSION AGREED TO THAT.
FINALLY WE ALSO VISITED A THREE
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES.
A REVIEW FOUND THAT THESE
COUNTIES WORK COMPLYING WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE AMATEUR SAY.
I SPECIFICALLY FIND THE THREE
COUNTIES WERE USING THEIR THREE
YEAR PLANS TO ALLOCATE THE IMAGE
SAY FUNDS. AND THEIR GENERAL
USING EFFECTIVE MONITORING
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS BEING SPENT APPROPRIATELY
AND CONSISTENT WITH THE THREE
YEAR PROGRAM PLAN.
US WITH ALL OF OUR AUDITS WE
FOLLOW UP WITH THE LOCAL
AGENCIES EVERY SIX DAYS SIX
MONTH AND ONE YEAR.
AND THE SIXTY DAY RESPONSE FROM
THE BILL OF THE DEPARTMENTS IS
DUE BY THE END OF THIS MONTH.
SO WE SHOULD HAVE OUR FIRST
RESPONSE TO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WANTED TO GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CENTER BELL WHO WAS THE
REQUESTER OF THIS AUDIT TO. BE
HAVE ANY.
OPENING REMARKS.
NOT TOO MUCH BECAUSE I WAS LATE
AND THEREFORE DON'T DESERVE TO
HAVE A LONG OPENING REMARKS OF.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
COMPLETING THEIR ADEN.
WE WILL USE THE AUDIT IN TERMS
OF LEGISLATION AND THEN.
THE BUDGET IN THE UPCOMING.
.
DELIBERATIONS OF THE STATE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY SO.
THE PURPOSE OF THE ARTISTIC KIND
OF.
YOU KNOW GIVE US.
A LOOK SEE.
AND AND AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES FOR THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS IS
USES THESE ARE THINGS WE KNOW
THAT WE NECESSARILY.
HAVE TO.
.
FOCUS ON TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS OF
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR WE SHARE
IT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM.
THE COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF THE
AUDIT FINDINGS.
SEEING NONE I. DID YOU WANT OKAY
ARE.
OKAY AT
BY DAVE IT IF IF THERE ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WILL STAY FOR
THE ENTIRE HEARING AFTER THE
OTHER PANELS.
A BIT OF MEMBERS AT HAVE ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AFTER YOU
HEAR FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
NOW CERTAINLY FROM THE STATE.
REPRESENTATIVES WOULD BE HAPPY
TO COME BACK UP OKAY THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO CALL UP
OUR NEXT PANEL WHICH IS.
.
TO HEAR FROM.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE MIMI MARTINEZ
MCKAY THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
ANGELA INGGRIS WELL I SHOULD I
SHOULD LEAVE EVERYONE.
TWO INTRODUCED THEMSELVES WE
HAVE REPRESENT US FROM LA COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
WELCOME EVERYONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
.
SO WE START WHAT LOGISTIC
APPEAR.
THE.
THAT THE PUBLIC AGENDA SO A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR MY NAME IS
MAYBE MARTINEZ MCKAY. I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR STRATEGIC
PLANNING FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES A POSITION I'VE HELD NOW
FOR EIGHT MONTHS.
AND I'LL SAY THAT THEY NON
NATIVE LOS ANGELES AND I SPENT
THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS AS
THEIR.
CHIEF OF STAFF OF LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE OF TEXAS
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
AND IN THAT POSITION IN TEXAS
WHEN I SAW THIS PROPOSITION
PASSED IN MY HOME STATE AND SAW
THE HOPE AND THE VISION BEHIND
IT. YOU'D HAVE TO SEE WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE FROM OUTSIDE RIGHT IT
WAS LIKE OH MY GOODNESS I MEAN
JUST HOPING THAT. A MOVEMENT OF
THAT KIND WOULD CONTINUE IN
OTHER STATES AND. ITS ATTENTION
FROM HEARINGS LIKE THIS BUT I
THINK WOULD BRING THAT ABOUT
LOOKING AT THE VISION LOOKING AT
WHERE THINGS NEED TO BE
CORRECTED POSSIBLY. AND THEN
MOVING FORWARD SO IT'S JUST
REALLY EXCITING TO BE HERE AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PANEL INTO THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
FOR PRODUCING THIS REPORT SO
WE'LL START WITH A FEW COMMENTS
ON THE REPORT ITSELF IN BRIEF
OUR PERSPECTIVE ON IT WHEN IT
WAS RELEASED.
.
LA COUNTY SUPPORTS THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF THE REPORT AND WELCOMES
ROBUST STATE LEADERSHIP AROUND
ALL IMAGES SAY PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES.
OUR PROCESS AROUND IMAGES
EXPENDITURES IN LA COUNTY IS
TRANSPARENT AND WE HAVE DETAILED
SPENDING PLANS POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE.
SO YOU KNOW WE THAT IS SOMETHING
I OVERSEE WEB SERVICES AND WE
ARE VERY CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PUT EVERYTHING OFF AND
LOOK FOR ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT ON EVERYTHING THAT
WE.
ALL OF OUR PLANS AND EVERYTHING
THAT GOES INTO OUR SPEND OUR
SPENDING AND I. HAD OUR FOCUS ON
EXPENDITURES.
WE ARE KEENLY FOLKS ON DRESSING
THE AREAS OF CONCERN IN OUR
COUNTY WITH THESE FUNDS
INCLUDING HOMELESSNESS OCCUR
INCREASING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT SERVICES
VETERANS SERVICES. CRISIS
SERVICES PREVENTION AND SAFETY
IN OUR SCHOOLS. WERE VERY
COMMITTED OUTCOME TRACKING
EXTERNAL EVALUATION AND BEST
PRACTICES TO GUIDE THE USE OF
ALL PUBLIC FUNDS.
INNOVATION OF COURSE IS A BIG
FOCUS AND WE'RE CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS ANALYTIC LIMITING
SILOS BETWEEN D. MH AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ON BEHALF OF ALL LA
RESIDENTS. LOOKING TO EXPAND
PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR PARKS AND
LIBRARIES ADDRESSING HEALTH
EQUITY AND TRAUMA AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND THEN OVER THE PAST YEAR AND
THIS IS SOMETHING I PERSONALLY
BEEN VARYING GEISHAS WE'VE HAD
AN UNPRECEDENTED DIALOGUE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE COUNTY
FOCUS ON CREATING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND AND AND BROADENING THAT
CIRCLE YOU KNOWS A LOT OF TIMES
YOU FIND YOURSELF IN ROOMS ARE
SURE YOU'LL NEVER EXPERIENCE
THIS WHERE IT'S A LOT OF THE
SAME FACES YOU KNOW AND WE HAVE
TEN MILLION PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTY.
SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
BROADEN THAT DIALOGUES ARE
BRINGING MORE PEOPLE INTO THIS
EQUATION BECAUSE I HAVE YET TO
FIND A FAMILY THAT IS NOT
TOUCHED BY MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO HOW DO ARE DOWN ON A COUPLE
OF THESE AREAS SHORTLY BUT I
ALSO WANT TO STRESS THAT THE
COUNTIES THE OIC AND THE STATE
AND IN OUR MIND NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A SEAMLESS
SYSTEM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE STATE
SPEECH HIEF ROLE OF
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS THE OIC
CREATING LINKAGES IN AFRICA.
EVALUATING EFFECTIVENESS
AND THE COUNTIES PROVIDING
EFFECTIVE SERVICES.
THAT SAME BROAD STROKES ALL OF
THAT IS OCCURRING BUT.
THERE ARE ISSUES AND SYSTEMS
THAT ARE CREATING BARRIERS AT
ALL LEVELS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS REPORT.
SHOW HOW SOME OF THAT ALIGNMENT
HAS BEEN LACKING AND THE WE ARE
AND ALWAYS GROWING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION.
AND FOR A COUNTY PERSPECTIVE.
.
IF WE LOOK AT THE STATE WE LOOK
AT THE STATE WIDE ENTITIES TO
HELP US FOSTER AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE OUR CLIENTS. DON'T HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WORK PROGRAMS WILL
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THEY NEED
AND EVEN MORE DAUNTING WHAT
FUNDING STREAMS WILL PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES. BUT EVERYDAY I
TALK TO CLIENTS AND FAMILIES AND
THEY HAVE HAD TO LEARN THE
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF ALL OF THE
ACRONYMS IN TERMS OF WHICH FUNDS
IN TERMS OF WHAT PROGRAMS. THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THAT THEY SHOULD THINK ABOUT
WHAT THEY NEED TO BECOME
HEALTHY.
AND NOT SEEK WE SEEM TO HAVE PUT
THEM INTO A SYSTEM WHERE THEY
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND. THE
BUREAUCRACY SOMETIMES TO GET
THOSE SERVICES AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE WE NEED TO CHANGE
THAT.
SO WE'RE ONLY TO DO A BETTER JOB
I THINK THE COUNTIES NEED TO
LOOK TO THE STATE TO STREAMLINE
PROPHECIES PROVIDE GUIDANCE IN
TERMS OF REGULATIONS AND
ESTABLISH POLICIES THAT CREATE A
STRUCTURE. THAT SUPPORTS
EFFECTIVE AND ACCOUNTABLE USE OF
FUNDS.
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK TO THE OIC
TO SUPPORT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COLLABORATION
AND MODELS OF EXCELLENCE WHICH
QUITE RECENTLY LA COUNTY HAS.
I HAD A REALLY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCEIN TERMS OF
INNOVATION THAT WE HAVE WORKED
WITH A KEY PARTNERS KERN COUNTY
BUT OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL. TO
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
INNOVATION SWEET WHICH WERE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT SO WE'VE
SEEN THAT REALIZED VERY CLOSELY
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE LA
CITY.
AND IN A MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
HAVE TO AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
SERVE ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS
SUPERVISORS THAT PROMOTE MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND NOT
HAVE TO HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THESE INTRICACIES.
SO I'D SAY FINALLY IN TERMS OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
WOULD LOOK TO.
THE FUNDS NEED TO BE FLEXIBLE TO
ADDRESS DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
FIELD. AND FUN THINGS.
THAT THAT ARE BENT AND FUNDS
BEYOND THOSE THAT ARE MARKED FOR
INNOVATION HAVE TO BE LOOKING AT
INNOVATIONS WE NEED TO ADDRESS
PRESSING NEEDS SUCH AS IN OUR
CARE IN OUR COUNTY HOMELESSNESS.
YOU KNOW NOT THAT WERE ONLY
ALLOWED IN THAT BUT AS EVERYONE
KNOWS MENTALLY COUNTY HAS A
PARTICULAR CHALLENGE THEIR AND
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IS VERY
FOCUSED BACK ON THAT.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE A LITTLE
STATEWIDE STORY AND WERE WERE
WERE AN ENORMOUS COUNTY BUT WE
NEED TO BE WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE OTHER COUNTIES TO TELL A
STORY ABOUT HOW THESE.
IF YOU KNOW THE VISION OF WHAT
WAS BEHIND THIS PROPOSITION AND
HOW WE NEED TO BE.
LOOKING AT MESSAGES THAT THAT
BETTER COMING FROM ALL OF THE
COUNTIES AND WORKING TOGETHER.
EVALUATION NEEDS TO BE INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL AND YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE RAND REPORT
THAT WAS RELEASED A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THE LOOK SPECIFICALLY
AT LA COUNTY. AND HOW WE'RE
REACHING THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THROUGH FIELDS FULL
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS AND
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FUNDING. THAT WAS
THE FIRST EXTERNAL EVALUATION
THAT WAS DONE RELATED TO THESE
FUNDS AND SO WE NEED A LOT MORE
OF THAT WE SUPPORT THAT AND WE
SUPPORT THAT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OF COURSE ARE AMAZING
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE ALSO NEED THAT BETTER
ALIGNMENT OF PROGRAMS THE AT
WITH THAT ARE.
LOOKING AT BOTH QUALITATIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE DATA SO WE'RE
LISTENING TO PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT DATA TO IMPROVE A SYSTEM.
BOTTOM LINE IS WE NEED TO BE IS
THAT NEEDS TO BE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN COMPARISON TO THE
TORMENT. TREMENDOUS WORK THAT IS
BEING ACCOMPLISHED OVER THE LAST
LAST FOURTEEN YEARS BUT THERE'S
A HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK TO COME SO
WE NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF THAT
AND WE GO WHERE. AS I SAID
BEFORE I COME FROM SOMEWHERE
WHERE THIS PROPOSITION WAS A
BEACON OF HOPE FOR THE COUNTRY
AND I THINK IT IS FOR THE WORLD
AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I NEXT SO WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM.
ANGELA THE A BRISSON ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF THANK YOU TO
SENATOR PELL AND THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR
ORDERING THE CITED THANK YOU
ALSO TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S FOR THE. EXCELLENT
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAD NO AUDIT
FINDINGS AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
TO REPORT THAT. OVER OUR FIVE
YEAR PLAN FOR EXPENDITURES WAS
APPROPRIATE INCLUDED A PLAN FOR
HOW UTILIZED A RESERVE INTERESTS
WE APPROPRIATELY MONITOR
PROJECTS AND VENDOR INVOICES SO
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THAT BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE BEAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT TO ME
MIMI DID A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING HOW THIS ACT HAS
TRANSFORMED THE LIVES OF SO MANY
PEOPLE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
THERE'S COUNTLESS NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTY WHO HAVE
BEEN TOUCHED BY THE SERVICES
WITHIN THIS ACT.
MORE SPECIFICALLY LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW PROGRAMS ONE
FROM EACH OF THE COMPONENTS OF
THE ACTOR AT LEAST THAT SERVICE
COMPONENTS.
THE FIRST FOR THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES ARE
MENTAL.
ARE MULTI DIMENSIONAL TREATMENT.
.
SORRY MULTI DIMENSIONAL.
AND YOU HAVE TO PROGRAM OKAY.
MY FIRST TIME TESTIFYING A
LITTLE TONGUE TIED BUT THIS IS A
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
IT SERVES YOUTH ON PROBATION.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE YOUTH ON
PROBATION THAT WE SERVE ARE
ACTUALLY OF LATINO DESCENT. AND
WE'VE HAVE FOUND THAT THIS
PROGRAM TREATS MENTAL ILLNESS
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE AT A RATE OF
A SIXTY PERCENT. DECREASE IN
ARRESTS.
EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT DECREASE IN
SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS.
AND A FIFTY PERCENT DECREASE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE EFFORTS OF
THIS DIRECTLY AS A RESULT OF THE
ACT.
SECONDLY FOR PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION WE'VE HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WITH OUR
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS AND
STIGMA REDUCTION CAMPAIGN.
WILL WILL ARE ANALYTICS
CONSISTS NOW SAY THAT EIGHTY ONE
PERCENT OF ALL RIVERSIDE COUNTY
RESIDENTS. KNOW ABOUT THE IT'S
UP TO US SUICIDE PREVENTION
CAMPAIGN IT GIVES ME GREAT HOPE
TO KNOW THAT THE RESIDENTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. KNOW ABOUT
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND HOW TO
ACCESS HELP IF THEY NEED IT.
OUR NETWORK OF CARE WEBSITE
YIELDED OVER SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND VIEWS LAST YEAR.
CELESTIAL DOT HAD LAID ARE IN OF
ONE OF OUR INNOVATION PROGRAMS
ARE COUNTY IS VERY WIDESPREAD
COUNTY AS I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
KNOW THERE'S.
ALL KINDS OF RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS WE HAD VIRTUALLY NO
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOU SERVICES
SERVICES FOR YOUTH SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE. AS A RESULT OF OUR
INNOVATIVE PROJECT WE'VE NOW
BEEN ABLE TO OPEN UP THREE.
VERY LARGE CENTERS TO SERVE TO
YOUTH.
THE COMPONENTS OF THE CENTERS
INCLUDE.
TREATMENT FOR FIRST EPISODE
PSYCHOSIS.
A SPECIALIZED IN UNIQUE TERRY
PEER EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PROGRAM.
S. PROGRAM ESPECIALLY TAILORED
FOR PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES BETWEEN THE AGES OF
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE.
AND A COMPREHENSIVE ONE STOP
SHOP FOR ALL YOUTH.
SO WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
ACT.
IN TERMS OF CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE WORK TODAY AS IT RELATES
TO THIS AUDIT WE'RE GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT
TWO MAJOR CHALLENGES.
THE FIRST ONE IS.
INCONSISTENT MESSAGES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES REGARDING THE RESERVE
FORMULAS.
HOW TO ACCESS THE RESERVES WHEN
NEEDED AND WHAT TO DO WITH ANY
INTEREST ACCUMULATED?
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
OVER CONFIDENT THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AUDIT.
SECONDLY LIKE TO EXPRESS THAT
IT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO GO
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
THE INNOVATIONS.
FUNDING.
LAST NOVEMBER. OF OUR COUNTY AND
I WAS ACTUALLY THERE PRESENTED
IN FRONT OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION REGARDING A HOSPITAL
INTERVENTION PROGRAM. THIS OF
PROJECT WAS A JOINT PROJECT WITH
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY WHO IS
VERY LARGE OUR STAFF WORKED VERY
LONG ON THIS PROJECT.
OUR STAFF MET WITH THE STAFF OF
THE OAC NO LESS THAN THREE TIMES
DURING EACH ONE OF THESE
MEETINGS WE WERE ASSURED THAT
OUR PROJECT WAS INNOVATIVE. THAT
WAS CONSISTENT WITH ALL THE
VALUES AND TERMS OF THE ACT.
WE WERE SURE THAT ONCE WE GOT
THERE THE OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
TO BE VERY EXCITED HERE WE HAVE
SAY. WE'RE VERY SURPRISED FIND
OUT WHEN WE GOT THERE THAT WE
WERE PRETTY MUCH CATEGORICALLY
DENIED.
WE WERE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING OUR PROPOSAL BACK
AGAIN.
BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE ARE
SPENDS A LOT OF TIME ON THIS
THERE IS A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
THERE'S WRITING THE ACT THERE'S
MEANING WITH THE OIC WE HAVE TO
GET BOARD OF SUPERVISOR APPROVAL
AND WE HAVE TO GET ON THE
CALENDAR FOR THE OAC SO ALL THIS
TIME GOES BY NINE TO TWELVE
MONTHS.
TAKING AWAY OUR MONIES ARE
SUBJECT TO REVERSION
SO WE WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
SOME ASSISTANCE IN GETTING SOME
CLEAR GUIDANCE ON WHAT IS
INNOVATIVE. WHAT ARE THE TIME
LINES HOW CAN WE GET ON THE
COUNTER FOR THE OAC?
SO IN SUMMARY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FULLY SUPPORTS THE FINDINGS OF
THE AUDIT.
THE HIGHLIGHT.
WE RECOMMEND IMPLEMENTING
STATUTORY LIMITS ON RESERVE
AMOUNTS CLEAR IN QUICK GUIDANCE
FROM THE OAC ON INNOVATION PLANS
CLEAR DIRECTION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES A RESERVE ALLOCATIONS.
AND FINALLY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK THE AUTHORS OF THE ACT WHO
HAVE SUCCEEDED IN REDUCING THE
SUFFERING SIGNIFICANTLY OF OUR
CITIZENS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT THAT
LIKE TO INVITE THE.
COUNTY SUPERVISOR PATRICK
KENNEDY REPRESENTING THE STOCK
MARKET ON PORTS SUPERVISORS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PATRICK
KENNEDY EMMA COUNTY SUPERVISOR
IN SACRAMENTO REPRESENTING
DISTRICT TO SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN. FIRST LET ME THANK YOU
FOR MAKING TIMEON YOUR AGENDA
TODAY FOR ME. I'M REPRESENTING
NOT ONLY SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT
ALSO THE YET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES DE SAC
WHICH IS A VOICE FOR ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN THIS IN THE
STATE.
I ALSO HAVE DIRECT EXPERIENCE IN
INSURING THE EFFECTIVE USE OF
MHSAA FUNDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION
ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE. A PROTECT
CRITICALLY MISTER BELL.
WE AND THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT NEED TO KNOW HOW
THIS CRITICAL REVENUES BEING
SPENT TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
THOSE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
SEE SEC SUPPORTS THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATION OF THE STATE
AUDITOR AND THE AUDIT REPORT.
LIKE THE MHSAA AUDIT THAT CAME
BEFORE THIS ONE THE COUNTIES
THAT PARTICIPATED ALAMEDA
RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO DID VERY
WELL AND WERE FOUND TO HAVE
COMPLIED WITH MHSAA LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
ALLOCATION OF THEIR IMAGES THAT
AS A FUNDING.
ONE POINT I MUST MAKE COUNTIES
ARE NOT SITTING ON THREE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN MHSAA DOLLARS AS
MENTIONED SO OFTEN.
CAN WE DO BETTER YES.
AB ONE FOURTEEN SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR LAST LEGISLATIVE
SESSION NOW GIVES COUNTIES THE
GUIDANCE THEY NEED TO SPEND THE
FUNDING.
COUNTIES ARE ACTING QUICKLY IN
MANY OF STARTED THEIR THIRTY DAY
PUBLIC COMMENT PROCESS TO INVEST
THESE DOLLARS NOW THAT THEY'VE
BEEN FREED UP.
WE WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR FOR CRAFTING AB ONE
FOURTEEN TO PROVIDE BETTER
OVERSIGHT OF IMAGE IT'S A
FUNDING.
AND TO ENSURE THE MONEY IS SPENT
THE WAY AS ENVISIONED IN PROP
SIXTY THREE.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE
PLAN FOR MY COUNTY IN
SACRAMENTO.
OUR PLAN TO REPURPOSE FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN WHAT WAS
CALLED I'M SPENT MHSAA FUNDING
RECENTLY TO ASSIST WITH THE
HOMELESS CRISIS.
HAS BEEN POSTED SINCE FEBRUARY
FIFTH THE MERE THIRTY SIX DAYS
AFTER AB ONE FOURTEEN WENT INTO
EFFECT.
WE ASK FOR PUBLIC INPUT
DEVELOPED A PLAN THAT WILL MAKE
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS IN CRISIS
SERVICES ELDER WELLNESS AND
HOMELESSNESS.
AS A RESULT WE ARE MEETING
TODAY'S NEEDS AND SPENDING FUNDS
THAT WERE ONCE CONSIDERED ON
SPENT.
THE AUDIT RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW COUNTIES CAN FUND.
CAN'T SPEND FUNDS ESPECIALLY
RELATED TO THE OAC PROCESS FOR
APPROVING INNOVATION FUNDS.
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION TO
THE OAC THAT IT PROVIDE CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IT EXPECTS FOR COUNTIES INVASIVE
PLANTS.
AFTER ALL SIXTY THREE PERCENT OF
THE UNSPENT FOR THE CURRENT
UNSPENT FUNDS.
TO REVIEW THE WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
REVERSION OUR INNOVATION FUNDS.
WE ALSO APPLAUD THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO CREATE AN
ACCEPTABLE MHSAA RESERVE LEVELS.
COUNTIES ARE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WORKS AS A PRUDENT RESERVE SO
THAT WE CAN RESPONSIBLY PLAN FOR
THE SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM.
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT NO
COUNTY BUILDS UP AN UNREASONABLE
LEVEL OF RESERVE.
THE FOCUS IS CLEAR COUNTIES MUST
USE MHSAA FUNDING TO MEET THE
KEEP COMMUNITIES NEEDS.
BUT TO DO THIS WE NEED THIS WE
NEED THE STATE AND D. H. AT CS.
TO GIVE COUNTIES CLEAR AND
TIMELY REPORTING TOOLS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE CORRECTED
VERSION OF THE MHSAA.
YEAR AND REPORTING FORM WAS
RELEASED IN LATE JANUARY A MONTH
PAST THE STATUTORY REPORTING DUE
DATE OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
COUNTIES TAKE THESE FORMS AND
REPORTS VERY SERIOUSLY AS THEIR
AUDITABLE AND MUST BE SIGNED
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY. BY
EACH COUNTY AUDITOR AND
CONTROLLER.
TO SUM UP MY COUNTY AND MY
COUNTY SUPERVISOR COLLEAGUES
AROUND THE STATE ARE WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT MHSAA FUNDING IS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE THE MENTAL
HEALTH. OF OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUPERVISOR I
LAST BUT NOT LEAST FOR THIS
PANEL BEFORE WE GO TO.
QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE IS.
MAGGIE MARRIAGE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STEINBERG
INSTEAD.
HI NICE TO BE HERE I'D LIKE TO
THANK.
SENATOR BALLOT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
SENATOR ROTH AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY.
I MAYBE MERIT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
WE ARE A NONPROFIT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
FOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUES OF BRAIN HEALTH.
AS MOST OF YOU ARE AWARE OUR
INSTITUTE WAS FOUNDED BY FORMER
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM DARRELL
STEINBERG AND HE'S ARE YOU NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE. AND SENDS HIS
REGARDS.
HE HAS BEEN A LEADING CHAMPION
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WAS THE AUTHOR OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
PART OF OUR MISSION AT THE
INSTITUTE IS TO SERVE AS A
STEWARD FOR THAT LEGACY.
ENSURING THE FUNDS IT GENERATES
FOR A STATE IS SPENT
STRATEGICALLY EFFECTIVELY AND
EQUITABLY.
AS SUCH
WE ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
ISSUES RAISED IN THE RECENT
AUDIT.
AND GRATEFUL TO THE STATE
AUDITOR FOR SHINING A LIGHT ON
THE NEED FOR STRONGER STATE
LEADERSHIP.
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR MENTAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM.
FOURTEEN YEARS AFTER PASSAGE
I FIND MYSELF THINKING THAT THE
MHSAA IS IN MANY WAYS A TALE OF
TWO CITIES.
ON THE ONE HAND IT IS ARGUABLY
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST
PUBLIC POLICY ACHIEVE IT
ACHIEVEMENTS.
YOU REMEMBER IN THOSE DIFFICULT
YEARS BEFORE PROP SIXTY THREE.
THERE WAS NO CONTINUE I'M A
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO SPEAK UP.
CALIFORNIA HAD EMPTIED OUT ITS
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS WITH THE
PROMISE OF BUILDING A FULL
SPECTRUM OF COMPASSIONATE
COMMUNITY BASED CARE.
BUT OUR LEADERS NEVER FOLLOWED
THROUGH ON THAT COMMITMENT.
INSTEAD WE GOT BUDGET CUTS.
WE HAD PEOPLE IN CRISIS AND KNOW
WHERE TO TREAT THEM.
OUR STREETS IN JAILS AND
EMERGENCY ROOMS BECAME TREATMENT
CENTER AS OF LAST RESORT.
FAMILIES HAD NOWHERE TO TURN FOR
HOPE.
AGAINST THAT BACKDROP.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT HAS BEEN A
GAME CHANGER FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR ALONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR IT WILL
GENERATE TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE SERVICES THAT HAVE
FLOURISHED BECAUSE OF THIS
FUNDING HAVE BEEN A LIFELINE FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
ACROSS THE STATE.
SOME OF THE GREATEST GAINS HAVE
BEEN AN AREA A FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS.
THE INTENSIVE SERVICES TARGETING
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HAVE FALLEN
OFF TRACK BECAUSE OF SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF MHSAA FUNDS
ARE DIRECTED TO THESE PROGRAMS.
MANY RECEIVING THE SERVICES ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS.
OR HAVE BEEN IN AND OUT OF JAIL
AND ARE IN AND OUT OF EMERGENCY
ROOMS BECAUSE THEIR ILLNESS IS
GONE AND TREATED.
THE FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS
PROVIDE HOUSING JOBS COUNSELING
EDUCATION.
MEDICATION DOES WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK ON
TRACK.
IT IS A DIFFICULT AND
PAINSTAKING WORK.
BUT IT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
SINCE TWENTY TEN
WE KNOW THAT MORE THAN EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE I BENEFITTED FROM THESE
SERVICES.
A RECENT RAND REPORT FOUND THAT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE FS
PIECE REACHED TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
TREATMENT SIDE DRAMATIC DECLINES
IN HOMELESSNESS AND DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT IN MENTAL HEALTH.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY PERCENT OF MH
AS A FUNDING JUST OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
DIRECTED TOWARD PREVENTION AND
EARLY OTHER INTERVENTION AND HAS
FUELED STATE OF THE ART PROGRAMS
IN POCKETS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT TARGET YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF MENTAL ILLNESS.
TO HELP THEM GET CONTROL OF
THEIR BRAIN ON THIS BEFORE IT
BECOMES DISABLING.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE HAVE THE
EAT OUT PROGRAM DOING AMAZING
WORK TO INTERVENE WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
PSYCHOSIS RELATED ILLNESSES LIKE
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND BIPOLAR
DISORDER.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS DOING
TREMENDOUS WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE GREAT RISK OF MENTAL
ILLNESS BECAUSE OF THEIR
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA.
THAT SAME RAND REPORT FOUND THAT
THE COUNTY HAD REACHED ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND AT
RISK KIDS WITH THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS AND WITH GREAT SUCCESS.
SENATE CLARA COUNTY IS LAUNCHING
A PROGRAM CALLED HEADSPACE.
A TERRIFIC PROGRAM OUT OF
AUSTRALIA THAT PROVIDES LOW COST
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO PEOPLE
AGES TWELVE TO TWENTY FIVE
WITHOUT STIGMA OR RED TAPE.
I SHARE THIS REMIND US ALL THAT
WHILE THE AUDIT RAISES
LEGITIMATE CRITICISMS ABOUT
UNSPENT FUNDS.
COUNTIES HAVE SPENT THE BULK OF
THEIR MHSAA REVENUE OVER THE
YEARS AND. THE STATE ABOUNDS
WITH SUCCESS STORIES.
WE'VE SEEN LIFESAVING
TRANSFORMATION
QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE WOULD BE TODAY WITHOUT THE
MHSAA.
BUT COULD IT BE HAVING EVEN
BIGGER IMPACT.
YES
WE BELIEVE MHSAA SHOULD AND
COULD. BE MAKING AN EVEN BIGGER
DIFFERENCE.
GIVEN THE FUNDS AVAILABLE AND
CALIFORNIA'S PROMINENCE IN
RESEARCH AND TECHNOLOGY WE
BELIEVE THE MEASURE SHOULD BE
DRIVING A SEISMIC SHIFT IN
APPROACH AND OUTCOMES. THAT
WOULD PROPEL US TO THE FOREFRONT
OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN OUR
NATION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT THERE
YET.
ARE HOMELESS NUMBERS CONTINUE TO
RISE BECAUSE OF UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS.
I SUICIDE RATES REMAIN
UNCHANGED.
SERVICES REMAIN FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON THE BACK END OF
CARE ON PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS
ARE HOSPITALIZED BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT HAVE ACCESS.
I CARE ON THE FRONT END AT STAGE
ONE.
MORE THAN A DECADE AFTER PROP
SIXTY THREES PASSAGE WE HAVE NO
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO SET A STATE
WIDE STRATEGIC VISION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SPENDING.
WE HAVE NO SYSTEM FOR COMPARING
IN SHARING OUTCOMES.
WE HAVE.
WE LACK THE CENTRALIZED
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. IS
SPENT STRATEGICALLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ON SERVICES WITH
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES.
AND WE STILL HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES DOING THINGS FIFTY
EIGHT WAYS.
IN SHORT WE HAVE A FAILURE NOT
OF FUNDING OR INTENT.
BUT OF LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
HIGHLIGHTS THE SHORTCOMING.
IT ECHOES THE NEED FOR EFFECTIVE
SERVICES AND TREATMENT.
AND FINDS COUNTIES ARE
DILIGENTLY TRYING TO CARRY OUT
THEIR MISSION.
BUT IT ALSO FINDS PROGRESS
TOWARD THAT MISSION HAS BEEN
HAMPERED BY INEFFECTIVE
LEADERSHIP AND OVERSIGHT.
WE AGREE WITHOUT FINDING
FOURTEEN YEARS AFTER THE PASSAGE
OF THE MHSAA MENTAL ILLNESS
REMAINS THE UNDER ATTENDED ISSUE
OF OUR TIME.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT IS GOING
TO CHANGE THAT IS STRONG AND
CONSISTENT LEADERSHIP AT EVERY
LEVEL OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AS THE AUDIT NOTES HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE GONE
UNSPENT BECAUSE COUNTIES ARE
UNCLEAR. ABOUT HOW TO SPEND
THEIR PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION DOLLARS.
ORDER WHAT CONSTITUTES A PRUDENT
RESERVE.
IN THE SHORT LIFESPAN OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT THIS
IS THE FOURTH EVALUATION TO
RAISE SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE STATE'S FAILURE TO OVER
SEED.
AND DIRECT MHSAA SPENDING.
THE TIME HAS COME TO TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT OUR LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE
AND TO DEMAND BETTER.
WE BELIEVE THAT TAKING OUR
SYSTEM TAKE CARE.
SORRY WE BELIEVE THAT TAKING OUR
SYSTEM OF CARE TO THE NEXT LEVEL
OF EXCELLENCE REQUIRES A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE IN LEADERSHIP
APPROACH.
WOULD CALIFORNIA BENEFIT FROM A
STANDALONE MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY.
I DEDICATED COMMISSIONER.
IS IT SIMPLY A MATTER OF PUTTING
THE RIGHT PEOPLE PEOPLE WITH A
VISION AND PASSION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. IN THE EXISTING
SLOTS.
OUR INSTITUTE HAS BEEN
RESEARCHING THIS ISSUE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO START FROM SCRATCH.
THE ANSWERS ARE OUT THERE.
WE RECENTLY PARTNERED WITH
SENATOR PAN TO BRING.
MENTAL HEALTH EXPERTS FROM
AROUND THE GLOBE WHO HAVE LED
THE WAY IN SCALING UP INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES ACROSS A BROAD
POPULATION.
THIS INCLUDED DOCTOR AND SELL
EVENT COMMISSIONER OF NEW YORK
STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
WHERE THEY HAVE SUCCEEDED IN
MAKING EARLY PSYCHOSIS AND
DETECTION AND TREATMENT.
PROGRAMS ACCESSIBLE TO YOUNG
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN CALIFORNIA FEWER THAN HALF OF
OUR COUNTIES OFFER SUCH
SERVICES.
WE BROUGHT IN DOCTOR PATRICK
MCCORVEY FROM AUSTRALIA.
I CAN'T A COUNTRY THAT HAS MADE
AFFORDABLE STIGMA FREE MENTAL
HEALTH ACCESSIBLE TO YOUNG
PEOPLE. VIRTUALLY IN EVERY
COMMUNITY.
IN CALIFORNIAWE HAVE JUST A
HANDFUL OF COUNTIES
EXPERIMENTING WITH A SIMILAR
MODEL.
THE COMMON THREADS IN ALL THESE
EFFORTS ARE BOLD VISION.
COMMITTED LEADERSHIP
AND CLEARLY DEFINED OBJECTIVES.
SO I COME BACK TO MY TALE OF TWO
CITIES
WITHOUT QUESTION MENTAL HEALTH
REMAINS OPPRESSION PRESSING
ISSUE. AFFECTING VIRTUALLY EVERY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT QUESTION COUNTIES HAVE
USED MHSAA TO BRING CARE AND
RELIEF TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES.
AND WITHOUT QUESTION WE CAN DO
EVEN BETTER.
IT'S TIME FOR US IS SQUARELY
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF HOW WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
THAT OVERSEES MENTAL HEALTH
DELIVERY EMBRACES THAT ISSUE
WITH PASSION AND DETERMINATION.
AND HELPS LEAD THE WAY TO ENACT
NEW ERA WE STAND READY TO HELP
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER BELL TERRIBLE รณ. PREPS
FOR ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
ANSWER.
.
AND MAYBE I'M ESPECIALLY
INTERESTED IN YOUR TAXES.
MY WIFE'S FROM TAXES.
.
ARE THERE ANY MODELS AND OTHER
STATES THAT ARE BETTER.
THEN CALIFORNIA'S MODEL FOR
DELIVERY. OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THAT WORK BETTER.
AT AND I WOULD INCLUDE LIKE.
STATES THAT PROBABLY MORE
ROBUSTLY FUN.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ARE THERE ANY EXAMPLES.
.
WE CAN LOOK OUT.
IN OUR STUDY OF MAKING AN
EFFECTIVE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA. AS FIRST QUESTION
THE SECOND ONE WOULD BE.
THEIRS BAND NAM A DESIRE TO
INTEGRATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
SYSTEMS WITH.
OTHER PHYSICAL HEALTH SYSTEMS.
THERE'S A DELIVERY OF.
INTEGRATED MEDICINE.
AND.
HOW IS THAT HELPED OR HURT?
?
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO.
SEVERELY NEEDY.
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
SO THOSE ARE TWO QUESTION OTHER
STATES.
AND.
THIS INTEGRATION MOVEMENT HOW
DOES IT HELP OR HURT.
OUR DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WELL WHEN YOU MENTION STATES IT
ALSO HAVE A GOOD DEAL OF FUNDING
THAT MIGHT LEAVE TEXAS OUT IN
MANY WAYS BECAUSE TEXAS IS NOT
ROBUST IF BILLY FUNDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE WAY WE ARE
CERTAINLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT SAID I SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS
IN TEXAS TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA WORK
PERFECTLY AND NOW I'M HERE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE ADVANCES
THAT WE'VE MADE IN TEXAS WHEN I
WAS THERE. TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
BEING A PERFECT EXAMPLE THAT
REALLY ISN'T AS FAR ALONG
HEARING CALIFORNIA'S IT IS
THERE.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS IN MY
BACKGROUND IS I'M A LIBRARIAN
AND I'M ALWAYS LOOKING AT MODELS
AROUND THIS THE COUNTRY AN AND
SEEING HOW GOVERNMENT CAN BE.
NOT RECREATING BUT CONNECTING
DOTS AND LOOKING FOR MODELS OF
EXCELLENCE AND THAT'S I'VE BEEN
BRINGING TO LA COUNTY THAT THAT
WASN'T ONE EXAMPLE. IN TERMS OF
IMMIGRATION I MEAN. YOU KNOW YOU
MENTIONED WITH PHYSICAL HEALTH.
AND OF CERTAINLY I THINK THE
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE INTEGRATION
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE WE DON'T IN LA
COUNTY I THINK WE VERY MUCH NEED
THAT AND YOU KNOW MY DIRECTOR
JOHN SHARON IS WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
CREATE THAT SYNERGY AND I SPENT
THE LAST TWO DAYS WITH THE HEAD
OF SAMPSON. TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF THESE ISSUES AND TALKING
ABOUT HOW EVEN THOUGH SAM'S OF
COURSE HAS EXISTED AS AN ENTITY
THAT DOES THAT COMBINATION
THEY'RE STILL FUNDING SILOS
BETTER INCREDIBLY UNFORTUNATE
AND I KNOW SHE'S WORKING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE A LOT OF THAT WOULD NEED
TO. START TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN BE LOOKING AT AT FUNDING
INTEGRATION WHICH IS WHAT GETS
OUT A LOT OF THE INTEGRATION
THAT WE NEED TO SEE.
YEAH LIKE GO WHEN WE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
HAD BUDGET PROBLEMS.
.
WE SIMPLY MERGE THE DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE CREATED THIS WE.
WE STEP A SEPARATE ALCOHOL AND
DRUG ABUSE IN A SEPARATE MENTAL
HEALTH AND.
THE KIND OF LIKE MERGE THE
LEVELS OF.
EXECUTIVE A EVEN THOUGH THE
FUNCTIONS STAYED THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE STILL THERE.
FUNCTIONS OF IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAMS BUT.
.
I'M KIND OF WONDERING IF THAT.
LEFT A VOID IN TERMS OF.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT AND I KNOW THERE IS I
BELIEVE PENDING LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD LOOK AT A DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH YEAH?
IN TEXAS THINKING HAPPEN
FOURTEEN AGENCIES TURNED INTO
FOUR AND THREE YEARS IN A APART
A LARGE PART OF THAT WASN'T SO
MUCH ABOUT THE VALUE OF
IMMIGRATION BUT SAVING MONEY
WHICH OF COURSE IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING WAS A CASE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THREE YEARS DOWN IT HAD NOT
SAVE MONEY INTERESTINGLY THAT
HAD CAUSED A GREAT DEAL OF
CONFUSION AMONG PEOPLE ON THE
FOCUS THAT HAD BEEN ON THE STAND
ALONE SUBSTANCE ABUSE. MENTAL
HEALTH WAS LOST IN MANY CASES
OKAY SO AROUND OTHERS HAVING
ITEMS TOUGHNESS YES I WON'T GO
INTO A LOT OF DETAIL HERE AND
I'M HAPPY TO.
FORWARD INFORMATION TO YOU
SENATOR ABOUT ON THE COMMITTEE.
BUT NEW YORK STATE REALLY AS A
MODEL THEY.
HAVE INDEPENDENT YOU KNOW
COUNTY THAT COUNTY SYSTEM
SIMILAR TO OURS THEY'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AT GETTING EARLY
PSYCHOSIS IDENTIFICATION
CHARACTER OUT THERE STATE THEIR
OF DIVERSE STATE. AND THEY ALSO
HAVE REGIONAL CENTERS THAT ARE
TASKED WITH WORKING WITH
COUNTIES IN THEIR REGION TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OTHER SUPPORT AND THEY ALSO
PROVIDE.
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO FOR JUST
LISTENING TO COUNTIES AND
HEARING WHAT THEY'RE NEEDING BUT
THERE IS YOU KNOW I DOCTOR AND
SULLIVAN IS A DEDICATED
COMMISSIONER.
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND. REALLY
A TRUE LEADER IT'S IT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE I'D BE HAPPY TO
FORWARD THAT INFORMATION TO YOU.
YOU. OPINION OF COUNTY.
SUPERVISOR OF THE.
LEADERS IN THE COUNTY HAVE.
I AGREE WITH NEW YORK STATE AND.
FOR CHILDREN SERVICES ANALYSIS
OF NEW JERSEY MIGHT BE USEFUL.
WHAT THEY DO NEW JERSEY'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU DESCRIBED?
THERE IT'S.
THE FUNDING STREAMS ARE
INVISIBLE TO THE CONSUMERS SO. A
HOWEVER NEW JERSEY WORK THAT OUT
IF YOU'RE A CHILD AND YOU NEED
HELP YOU CALL THIS ONE LINE. OF
ITS AND THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE BILL BY THE STATE BEHIND THE
SCENES IT'S VERY INTERESTING SO
IT'S WORTH UNITS WERE SOME
ANALYSIS.
BUT HOW DO A MISTER CHAIRMAN
TOLERATE.
SARAH MORE ELECT AND SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK
YOU PANEL I APOLOGIZE THAT.
WE GET TO RUN IN AND OUT SO BY
HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF MEETING
WITH ELAINE HOW. AND HER TEAM.
BUT I'D LIKE TO.
FOLLOW UP SO MET MISS MERIT.
.
THERE WAS WITH DARRELL STEINBERG
LAST WEEK WITH SP ONE ZERO ZERO
FOR THE WINTER BILL SO THANK YOU
FOR.
PORT ON THAT BILL BUT I'M
CURIOUS MAYBE TO SET UP FOR THE
NEXT SESSION.
THE FLOW OF FUNDING.
SO THE THE GROUP WE PREPARE THE
INCOME TAX A GHOST OF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD GOES TO THE
CONTROLLER. AND THEN IT GOES TO
THE COUNTIES AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
YOU KNOW I DON'T THERE IS A LIST
OF AYE DEPARTMENTS THAT RECEIVE
MHSAA FUNDING BUT IN TERMS OF
THE COUNTIES ON A MONTHLY BASIS
THEY RECEIVE AN ALLOCATION OF
MHSAA FUNDS.
OKAY AND THEN THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO COME UP WITH.
INNOVATION PLANS AND COME UP
WITH THINGS
AND IT WAS A REAL BLESSING FOR
ORANGE COUNTY YOU KNOW DURING
THE RECESSION TO START HAVING
THAT. PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDING
COMING IN BUT.
BUT WHO THEN APPROVES THE
INNOVATION PLANS AND HOW DOES
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FIT INTO THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE OF THE
INNOVATION PLANS AND YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM TOBY EWING WHO CAN
GO INTO MORE DETAIL. BUT I
COUNTY.
EACH COUNTY AND ACTUALLY I WE
HAVE. PEOPLE RIGHT HERE THAT
COULD ACTUALLY ANSWER THIS
QUESTION PROBABLY BETTER THAN ME
BUT FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
COUNTIES.
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
THEY COME UP WITH A PLAN TO HAVE
A CUP PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
THEY GO BEFORE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT TALK ABOUT THAT
PLAN GET APPROVAL AND THEN THEY
GO TO THAT.
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND FOR FINAL
APPROVAL. AND SO IF THE
COMMISSION SAYS NO WE DON'T LIKE
YOUR PLAN.
TYPICALLY THAT COMMISSION WOULD
GIVE.
REASONS OF WE DO NOT THINK THEY
WOULD GIVE AYE INPUT AS TO WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHANGED.
AND THE COUNTY'S BASICALLY HAVE
TO GO BACK AND.
AND OF.
WORK ON THAT.
THAT PROPOSAL AND THEN COME BACK
AGAIN YES HAS THIS BEEN A REASON
FOR. SOME OF THE FUNDS.
ACCUMULATING WITHOUT BEING SPENT
THIS PROCESS OF TRYING SOMETHING
AND THEN GETTING A KICK BACK.
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND I I
OULDN'T.
DOUBT IT BUT FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND NINETY PERCENT OF THE
INNOVATION PROPOSALS THAT COME
BEFORE THE OECD ARE APPROVED.
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MEANS
IT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S A COUPLE
AT BATS BEFORE THAT APPROVAL
HAPPENS BUT.
I'M.
YOU MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY I'D
LIKE YEAH. I CAN SAY THAT A
THERE'S ALSO THERE'S ACTUALLY A
ADDITIONAL STEPS IN THE PROCESS
OF HAVING TO GO BEFORE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT STEERING
COMMITTEE. HAVING NO BEFORE THE
MENTAL HEALTH BOARD OF THE
COUNTY.
BEFORE EVEN GETTING TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SO IT IS QUITE CUMBERSOME AND.
IT DOES NOT EXACTLY SPEED UP
THE FLOW OF THE MONEY YEAH I SEE
A RATHER LENGTHY PROCESS AND
THAT'S WHY I'M. ASKING SOME
QUESTIONS ON WHAT CAN WE DO.
THE CAMERA MOVES ALONG BECAUSE I
SEE A PARALYSIS ICF FEAR OF A
LIABILITY EXPOSURE BUT IF WE DO
SOMETHING AND THEN.
SOMETHING SOMEBODY SUSAN SAYS
YOU SHOULDN'T BEEN USING PROP
SIXTY THREE FOR FOR THIS OR FOR
THAT WERE SENIOR RIGHT NOW WITH
NO PLACE LIKE HOME JUSTIN'S ARE
TIGHT AROUND SUPERIOR COURT
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE WANNA. BUILD
NEEDED HOUSING AND NOW WE'VE GOT
ONE PERSON WHO'S YOU KNOW
HOLDING IT UP AT ALL THAT.
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE YOU KNOW WITH THIS LOGJAM
WORSE TO PRUNE JUICE YOU KNOW
WHAT WE. WHAT WE DO AT TRYIN?
FREE THINGS UP A LITTLE.
MULDER NOW THAT THEY'VE HAD.
IF YOU LOOK AT.
WELL AGAIN I THINK YOU'LL HEAR.
FROM TOBY EWING AS SOON WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO GO INTO DEPTH
ABOUT THE WORK THEY'RE DOING.
THEY RECENTLY.
HOSTED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH US
SEVERAL DIFFERENT GROUPS AND
INNOVATION SUMMIT THAT BROUGHT
REALLY CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS INTO
THE SAME ROOM WHERE THEY BEGAN
TO TALK ABOUT REALLY JUST FROM
THE.
NOT BASIC POINT OF WHAT IS
INNOVATION AND I THINK THAT'S A
POINT THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED FOR COUNTIES AND I
ALSO KNOW. THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION IS
WORKING TO PROVIDE COUNTIES MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BUT I.
YOU'RE YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
YOUR POINT THERE IS PROBABLY
SOME STREAMLINING THAT COULD BE
DONE AND I. I THINK THAT THAT WE
SEE IS WORKING ON.
TOWARD THAT.
WELL YOU SAID THERE IS NO
STATEWIDE STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING. AND DARRELL STEINBERG
SAID THE SAME THING LAST WEEK
THERE JUST NO LEADERSHIP. THOSE
BEATS OKAY WELL I THINK THAT'S A
PRETTY STRONG INDICTMENT SO IS
THIS AUDIT.
YEAH AND SO IN MY COUNTY I HAVE
A FEDERAL JUDGE USE.
SORT OF TAKEN A TIGER BY THE
TAIL. AND MOVING OUT HOMELESS
CAMPS AND GIVING VOUCHERS YEAH
SO THAT'S GOOD FOR A MONTH BUT
WHAT YOU DO AFTER THIRTY DAYS I
MEAN THIS IS.
SORT OF A STRANGE LIKE THE
PHENOMENON AND AND AND I'M
WONDERING HOW DO WE GRAB THIS
TIGER BY THE TAIL AND START.
MOVING THINGS BECAUSE.
I HAVE A FEDERAL JUDGE AND SEES
A BIG BALANCE ON THE COUNTY
BOOKS I'M GETTING SUPERVISORS
THAT ARE BEING. YOU KNOW
RIDICULED AND PUBLIC.
YEAH I'M WATCHING MY MHSAA
REPRESENTATIVE RESIGN AND THEN
LEAVE WITHIN TWO DAYS AND EDITS
IT'S REALLY AWKWARD AND IT'S
IT'S AT.
AS I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IS AS ONE PERSON IN ONE COUNTY
OF THREE MILLION PEOPLE HOW TO.
GET THIS THING WORKING AND
WORKING RIGHT SO EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS IT SO.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU JUST
SENATOR PAN FOR RELEASED
PUTTING SOME SOME THAT EXPERTS
TOGETHER I'M JUST WONDERING
SINCE I'M A MANAGER NOT A
DOCTOR.
THAT I KNOW HOW DO I GET IT TO
MANAGE.
PROPERLY SO THAT WE CAN.
NOW GET THE BALL ROLLING BECAUSE
THIS IS A GLORIOUS OPPORTUNITY.
AND IT'S BANK ACCOUNTSTARTS
CHEWING
EVERYBODY OUT.
THAT'S JUST IT JUST.
IT'S JUST
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND IT'S
AWKWARD. IF IF I MAY YOUNG CLEAN
UP SOME THE PROOF PRUNE JUICE
MAY COME FROM A GREATER
CLARIFICATION AND GREATER
DIRECTION THAT THAT THE AUDIT
CALLS FOR. AYE AT THIS TIME
COUNTIES ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT MEANS WHAT IS
INNOVATIVE AND
IF WE HAD GREATER DIRECTION WE
WE COULD ACT IN A FASTER.
BUT YOU'VE GOT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE OR MENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS YOU'VE GOT AN
ASSOCIATION.
AND AND I I'M FINDING IT'S A
FORMER SUPERVISOR.
THAT APPEAR  EATEN WE DON'T
JUST CALL DEPARTMENT HEADS AND
AND SAY PICKS THAT. AFFECTS YOU
GOT YOUR BILL.
YOU KNOW TELL NOT MANAGE WHICH
IS REALLY CRAZY WHICH MEANS
THAT.
YOU SHOULD HAVE COME UP WITH THE
BILL.
OR GIVEN SOMETHING TO ONE OF US
LIKE CENTER BELL JUST BEEN A
STAR IN THE MENTAL HEALTH ARENA.
AND AND WE GET A CHAMPION THAT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
THINGS MOVING SO WHERE IS YOUR
BILL.
RICHARD I THINK.
ON THAT NOTE I HAVE WE DEL
STEINBERG INSTITUTE DOES HAVE A
PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION THAT
SEEKS TO.
VALLEY STANDARDISING CARE I
THINK WHEN DARRYL AND.
RUSTY FELIX WROTE PROP SIXTY
THREE.
THEY KNOW RIGHTLY SAW THAT
COUNTIES ME ED FLEXIBILITY LA
COUNTY IS DIFFERENT THE MONA
COUNTY THEY NEED FLEXIBILITY.
NOW DARRYL IF HE WAS HERE WOULD
SAY THAT IN HINDSIGHT NOW HE.
I HE WOULD NOT AGREE THAT THEY
NEED A HUNDRED PERCENT
FLEXIBILITY THEY DO NEED
FLEXIBILITY BUT WE ALSO NEED.
TO HAVE STANDARDS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT PROVIDE
EARLY CARE. EARLY QUALITY CARE.
AND.
SO THAT'S WHAT S. B. TEN ALL
FOR.
THAT YEAR AUTHORING WITH A
SENATOR WIENER THAT SEEKS TO DO
WHERE WE IDENTIFY PRIORITIES AND
SAY TO COUNTIES THAT. THEY MUST
SPEND THEIR PIII DOLLARS
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION DOLLARS.
ON ONE OF THESE THREE THINGS
EARLY PSYCHOSIS IDENTIFICATION
AND SERIOUS MOOD DISORDER.
.
TRANSITION AIDES YOUTH AND WITH
THAT FOCUS ON THAT CAN MAKING
CONNECTIONS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AS WE HAVE.
TWO HUNDRED.
STUDENTS ON OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES
DYING FROM AYE SUICIDE ANNUALLY
EVERY YEAR WE LOSE TWO HUNDRED
KIDS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
UP FROM SUICIDE AND.
NORTHERN PRAIRIE.
BAKER YES TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
RIGHT IN THEM WE HAVE ALL SEEN
THOSE STUDIES THERE WAS JUST A
BRILLIANT.
COMMITTEE MEETING THAT TALK ALL
ABOUT ACES ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND FROM THAT WE WE
KNOW THAT.
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE
EARLY IN THEIR LIVES AND
PROVIDE.
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES THE KIND
OF SUPPORT AND CARE THEY NEED
THEY GET TO THRIVE. THEY GET TO
THRIVE IN THEIR LIFE SO THAT'S
WHAT TEN OH FOUR IS WE HAVE A
WHOLE BILL LISTS A AND WITH
ABOUT SEVEN TOP PRIORITIES
CHANNEL FOUR IS OUR TOP. BUT I
THINK MORE DIRECTION AND THEN
BESIDES THAT IS UNTIL LOOK TO
THE STATE SO I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
NEW NEW JERSEY THAT WHAT IT WAS
I WILL LOOK INTO THAT. AT LIKE
AND NEW YORK LIKE WE KNOW HOW TO
DO IT RIGHT RENO WHAT WORKS
SO WE NEED.
AND WHAT THE AUDIT REALLY
FOCUSES ON IS LEADERSHIP.
AND WE THINK THAT'S TRUE WHEN WE
ARE READ THROUGH THE AUDIT.
.
I DON'T KNOW THE RESPONSES TO
THE AUDITOR'S REQUESTS AND.
SUGGESTIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT.
LACK LUSTER.
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S TIME FOR
THOSE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING MENTAL SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY LEAN IN.
AND THAT THEY REALLY DO YOU.
IDENTIFY MENTAL HEALTH IS A TOP
PRIORITY AND THEY CONDUCT
THEMSELVES IN THAT SAME WAY.
THANK YOU MISS MERIT THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME PICK ON YOU A
LITTLE.
RIGHT MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MURATSUCHI AND
I'M NOT A MEMBER OF JAIL LACK BY
PRESHEAF THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
NOVICE THESE IS AN ISSUE OF
GREAT INTEREST DAHLE THANK
CENTER BELFER. HELPING INITIATE
THIS AYE THAT NO ONE THINK
OTHERS FOR YOUR.
EXCELLENT WORK.
MEAL WE ACTUALLY DID DO.
TOUCH ON THIS ISSUE AT A
HEARING OF THE.
BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES BECAUSE AS WE WERE
DOING OUR OVERSIGHT OVER DAMAGE
TO SAY TO THE BUDGETARY PROCESS.
I A.
DO WHAT TO. ASK COUPLE QUESTIONS
OF THE GROUP HERE. THAT SERVE
RELATES TO SOME OF THE THINGS
FOUND THE OUT OF BUT TO SERVE
STEPPING BACK AND LOOKING
SUBSISTENCE ISSUE SO.
SO I GUESS THE FIRST QUESTION I
HAVE IS THAT.
WHEN THE EMMY TO SAVE US PASSED
IT DID INCLUDE A CERTAIN LEVEL
OF POTENTIALLY STATE OVERSIGHT
THROUGH THE INITIATIVE.
AND.
WE HAVE THE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION SO FORTH I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NO TO THAT.
THAT COUNTIES ALSO RECEIVE.
FAIRLY LARGE SOME ACTUALLY
PROBABLY ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ROUGHLY ARE THE SAME
SIZE OR LARGER THAN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM AS WELL FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AS WELL AND OF COURSE THAT.
IS DONE THE.
UNDER A DIFFERENT SET OF RULES
AND SOME SENSES AND HOW ONE CAN
ARGUE ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THAT IN TERMS OF
OF THAT IN TERMS OF.
RESPONSIVE THE STATE ARE SO SO
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR
SPECIALLY THE COUNTY.
WE HAVE VARIOUS CAL YEARS IS
THAT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS HOW WE
INTEGRATE?
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO GET TO.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS OUR
MENTAL HEALTH GOALS OVERALL I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD
YEAH AND IT WAS TOUCHED ON ABOUT
FUNDING STREAMS AND SO FORTH YOU
HAVE MHSAA MONEY YOU HAVE
MEDICAID MONEY.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH YOU GOT SOME
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING BUT I
THINK THOSE ARE TWO BIG ONES.
HOW DO THEY COME TOGETHER?
AND SAID SAYING WELL MEDI CAL
MONEY HAD DOES THIS AND AND I
SYSTEM IS GONNA DO THAT BECAUSE
BASICALLY.
WE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
THAT RUN ACROSS COUNT HOW.
HOW HOW DO WE GET?
HOW DO
WE GET A UNIFIED THEIR
COLLECTIVE YOU KNOW?
SALAS YOUR HOW A MENTAL HEALTH
GOALS COUNTIES AND HOW THEN IS
THAT.
RELATE TO THE CHEATING STATE
MENTAL HEALTH GOALS SO HE SPEAK
TO HOW EACH COUNTY LOOKS AT AND
IT'S A SAY IN THE MATTER CAL AND
HOW DO THEY TRY TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER ARE NOT TO OR ANYTHING
CITY TO GO ABOUT WATER MENTAL
HEALTH GOALS ARE.
YOU HAVE TO DRUM FOUGHT MY ONE
FRANKLY DOESN'T HAVE.
AS MUCH YOU KNOW I LEASE OF AND
IT'S A SAD DRIVE BECAUSE WAS
INITIATIVE THERE SOMEBODY YOU
HAVE TO GO CHECK IN WITH.
AND WE HAVE FACT INSURE DHS
WILL BE UP YOUR LITTLE LATER
BUT.
ON THE MEDI CAL SIDE I THINK
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN
THERE'S VERY LITTLE BASICALLY
STATE DOLES OUT THE MONEY AND WE
DON'T HEAR MUCH ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVELY IT'S BEING USED.
AND BACK EVEN CMS HAS POINTED
THAT OUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS A PARTNER IN THE
MEDICAL SIDE HAS. HAS ACCURATE
CRITICIZED ON CALIFORNIA FOR NOT
DOING ENOUGH OVERSIGHT OVER DOES
FUNDS AND YET THAT'S A. NORMAL
STRUCK A MONEY AS WELL SO HOW
HOW WE PUT ALL THOSE PIECES
TOGETHER.
WELL ONE OF THE THINGS I GOT A
COUPLE COMMENTS COME TO MIND ONE
IS INTERNALLY YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE HAD A STRUCTURE IN
TOTAL OUR NEW DIRECTOR STARTED
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO THAT
WAS REALLY DRIVEN BY. FUNDING
STREAMS MORE THAN DRIVEN BY
ALLOCATION OF OUR SERVICES AND
HOW WE ARE PROMOTING HEALTH
ACROSS THE COUNTY SO WE HAVE IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS ACTUALLY
TOTALLY REDONE THAT SO IT'S NO
LONGER DRIVEN BY FUNDING STREAMS
IS DRIVEN BY. PROGRAMS AND
OUTCOMES AND DATA AND NOT
LOOKING AT IT IN DIFFERENT POTS
WE ALSO OF COURSE PART OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT AS
WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT REQUIRES
A LOT OF THAT STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. SO WE HAD TO
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT WAS
LOOKING AT IMAGES A DOLLARS AND
THEY WERE ASKING US WHY REALLY
LOOKING AT IMAGES A DOLLARS THAT
DOES MAKE SENSE WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
RIGHT AND SO WE AND THAT
APPARENTLY PEOPLE TELL ME WHAT
BEFORE THIS PAST THERE WAS SUCH
A GROUP SO NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT THAT WAY IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOLISTICALLY BECAUSE
I SAID IN MY COMMENTS. PEOPLE
SHOULDN'T BE THINKING ABOUT
THOSE FUNDING STREAMS WE NEED TO
OF COURSE IN TERMS OF THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS AROUND THEM BUT
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THAT SHOULD
NOT BE DRIVING THE SYSTEM.
SO AT LEAST INTERNALLY AS WELL
AS THOR STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY. AND HE SAID YOU
START DOING THAT HOW LONG AGO
WELLS ARE DIRECTOR STARTED A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WHEN I
STARTED EIGHT MONTHS AGO WE
LOOKED AT THE WAY THE SYSTEM WAS
I MEAN MY FIRST DAY I TRIED TO
GET AN ORG CHART IS LIKE NO NO
NO. IT'S CHANGING SO AGAIN I
MEAN WE CAN ONLY SPEAK TO WHAT
YOU KNOW DOCTOR SHARON AND I
HAVE BEEN DOING SINCE WE CAME ON
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT DOING IT
VERY DIFFERENTLY. AND AGAIN
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF OF INPUT
FROM AROUND THE COUNTY FOR AS
INCLUDING FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AND ARE CEO'S OFFICE THAT ARE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS NEW
STRUCTURE.
AND CERTAINLY STAKEHOLDERS SO
YOU KNOW AGAIN WE WERE NOT DONE
BUT WE'RE DEFINITELY ALONG THE
WAY.
AND I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
AND GET FOR IT IS LIKE HOW MANY
OTHER COUNTIES DO IT THAT WAY.
THAT YOU CAN.
OF WHAT YOU'VE DESCRIBED IS AS A
MY MY LIFE EVERY DAY HAVE. IS
HAVE BALANCING THE FUNDING
STREAMS WITH THE PROGRAM NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND THE WAY THAT THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE IS THE CURRENT FUNDING
STRUCTURE.
DOES APPEAR TO BE VERY
SEDUCTIVELY ENTICING COUNTIES TO
GO BY FUNDS DRIVEN VERSUS.
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN.
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITIES AROUND THE FUNDING
AND THE AND THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
OF EACH COUNTY THAT'S A VERY
STRONG. ARGUMENT FOR KEEPING THE
MHSAA FUNDING LOCALLY
CONTROLLED.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE A COUPLE OF
THE MAIN POTS OF MONEY OF THEM
SURE YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS TO TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS.
IF YOU'VE EVER LOOKED AT THOSE
REALIGNMENT FORMULAS THEY ARE
DEFINITELY SOMETHING TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
IN OUR COUNTY WE HAVE THE
FOURTH LARGEST POPULATION THE
STATE. AND.
I THINK WE GET MAYBE FIFTY
SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY NINE EIGHT AT
THAT YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF OUR
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS.
SO WE HAVE TO BALANCE OUR MEDI
CAL REALIGNMENT DOLLARS WITH
THIRTY PST TEA WITH OUR MISSILE
DOLLARS. AND STILL PROVIDE THE
BEST SERVICE THAT WE CAN TO OUR
COMMUNITIES SO IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED SITUATION.
ARE COUNTIES UNDER HIRING
FREEZE RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT STRUCTURAL DEFICITS
BECAUSE OFFERS ALL THE THINGS
COME INTO PLAY WITH A FUNDING
STREAMS.
SO IT'S COMPLEX.
I I KNOW IT'S COMPLICATED BUT
ALREADY DOING THE WORK MAKE IT
ALL I HEAR LA COUNTY IS DOING
THAT.
WHAT YEAH WHAT WE DO TO MAKE IT
WORK WHAT WE'VE HAD TO?
PAUL THESE THINGS TOGETHER RATE
OF
KING AT THEM AS.
WELL WECONTINUE TO FOCUS ON HER
STAKEHOLDER INPUT I MEAN MIMI'S.
APPROACH IS EXACTLY WHERE WE
WERE ALWAYS NEEDING TO BE IS
WHAT DID THE STAKEHOLDERS WANT
AND HOW CAN WE MAKE IT HAPPEN.
SO.
ARE A REALIGNMENT DOLLARS GO
TOWARDS ARE SHRINKING HOSPITAL
BEDS.
IT WE'VE GOT IT GOING OFF TOPIC
A LITTLE BIT IF YOU KNOW THE
CRISIS OF OF HOSPITALIZATION
BEDS SO USED MS SIXTY DOLLARS TO
FUND THAT THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP THE HOMELESS
PROGRAMS.
SO WE WORK ON A CONTINUUM OF
CARE WHERE WE KNOW EACH FUNDING
STREAM CAN FIND A LITTLE BIT OF
A DESCRIPTIVE OF ADAPTING TO THE
DETAILS EXACTLY HOW WHAT YOU
DECIDED TO DO SO THERE IS A.
UNIFIED PROCESS AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TO DEVELOP A ESSENTIALLY
A SO
THAT THE PLAN FOR ALL OF MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE COUNTY YES
ACTUALLY THROUGHT AND STATE YOUR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS ACTUALLY
LIKE LA EX ENCOMPASSES ALL THE
FUNDING NOT JUST I MEAN TO SAY.
IT IT HAS TO ITEM NO YES. OKAY
WE WILL ALSO HAVE A CONSULTANT
IN OUR COUNTY RIGHT NOW WHO'S
HELPING US OUTSIDE OF KPMG IS.
COMING DOWN IN MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
CENTER PANDA IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I.
IF YOU HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION I
DO HAVE AN OAK FELT QUESTION SO.
THE OTHER QUESTION ACTUALLY I
WAS TESTIFIED ABOUT THE STATE'S
STRATEGIC PLAN I'LL SAY I HAVE A
BILL.
TO URGE FOR A SENSUALLY TO MAKE
A STEP TOWARD THE STATE'S
STRATEGIC PLAN.
I'VE DECIDED IN THAT BILL NOT TO
BE SPECIFIC PRESCRIPTIVE ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD BE IN AT WE HAVE A
PROCESS.
AND BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SAID WHEN
YOU SEE STRATEGIC PLAN.
MANY SAVE ELEVATION CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW I'VE SUPPORTED.
SIR WINNERS BILLS WELL WHICH IS
TO SPECIFY CERTAIN THINGS RIGHT
NOW BUT WE ALSO KNOW THINGS CAN
EVOLVE OVER TIME WE HAVE NEEDS
GOVERNOR HE'S.
THAT AND OTHER SITUATIONS CHANGE
AT IS THAT SOMETHING STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IS I MEAN I HEAR YOU
TESTIFYING ONCE THESE FEW PLAN
WILL BE SUPPORTING.
WE WOULD LOVE TO LOOK AT YOUR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND THE
FOLLOWING WE HAVE HOARDED DO
YOU.
OUR PARTNERSHIP.
YEAH.
KEEPING IN LEADERS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ON THAT NOTE
THAT WE WANT TO THANK A. OF THIS
PANEL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN.
APPEAR.
ALL RIGHT NEXT.
COMMENTS AND RESPONSES.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
OUR AND THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
GREAT SO.
WHEN THE PERSON.
YOU DON'T HAVE A.
THANK YOU FOR A PERHAPS IF IF
YOU CAN TRY TO. AYE KNOW I
INITIALLY SIT FIFTEEN MINUTES
AND SO. IF YOU NEED THE FULL
FIFTEEN DE BUT.
OTHERWISE WE
I THINK WE WANT TO HAVE A.
OPPORTUNITY TO.
ENGAGED IN THAT.
RIGHT A DISK I'M SO GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER CAN.
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND I
DEFINITELY WILL NOT TAKE THE
FULL FIFTEEN MINUTES.
I WANT TO SAY FIRST.
IN RECOGNITION OF WHAT WAS AND
MENTIONED IN THE LAST PANEL.
THE POSITIVE ABOUT THE IMAGE TO
SAY IS THAT CALIFORNIA DID.
MANY MANY YEARS AGO TAKE A STEP
TO AND ACTIVISTS A SOLID FUNDING
STREAM THAT WAS DEDICATED TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES LONG
BEFORE. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WERE.
AGAINST POPULAR IN THE HEALTH
UP POLICY WORLD AND OBVIOUSLY
SENATOR BELL.
BACK WHEN HE WAS A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BELL HAS DONE
BEEN LEADING THE WAY IN TERMS OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH CONVERSATION.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
JUST FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH OUR PROGRAM
IN OUR DEPARTMENT AS.
AS WE ARE THERE ARE FOUR MAIN
FUNDING STREAMS THAT COUNTIES
USED TO PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SO
THERE'S THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS THERE'S A
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS SHOULD THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SUB ACCOUNT.
THERE ARE IMAGES SAY DOLLARS
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF GENERAL
FUND OBVIOUSLY FOR THE PIECES
THAT WE FUND AND THEN THERE IS
I'M FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION THAT COMES
THROUGH.
THE MEDICAID SIDE.
IT IS.
EACH FUNDING STREAM AS YOU JUST
HEARD HAS ITS OWN ON
PACIFIC RULES AND REGULATIONS
FOR WHICH WE ARE.
OVERSEEN THOSE I'M FUNDS I
THINK THE BENEFIT.
LIES IN EACH
AND THEIR.
BOTH EITHER FLEXIBILITY OR IN
THERE ON DEATH
SO WHILE YOU WILL HEAR A LOT OF.
CONSTRAINTS AND RULES AND
REGULATIONS AROUND MEDICAID
DOLLARS ON THOSE OUR ENTITLEMENT
DOLLARS WHICH MEANS THAT THERE
UNLIMITED SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
A COUNTY HAS.
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WITH
MEDICAL NEEDS FFP AND THOSE
ASSOCIATED FEDERAL FUNDS ON FLOW
FOR AS MANY PEOPLE THAT NEED THE
SERVICE AND THAT IS THE ONE
BENEFIT OBVIOUSLY. TO WHAT FFP
BRINGS TO THE.
OVERALL DELIVERY SYSTEM
THE BEAUTY AND THE BENEFIT OF
ANY TO SAY DOLLARS AS THAT THEY
ARE INFINITELY MORE FLEXIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT HOW THEY WERE
INTENDED TO BE USED AS HOW THEY
ARE BEING USED.
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDS SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
MUCH MONEY MHSAA HAS.
BEEN COLLECTED OVER THE LAST.
MANY YEARS FOR THE SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE ATTACKS.
ESPECIALLY.
AND SINCE WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
I'M DATING BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE YOU HAVE APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT HAS BEEN COLLECTED
AND DISTRIBUTED TO THE COUNTIES
THE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
MILLION.
.
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF THE AUDIT
THAT IS SUBJECT TO REVERSION IS
ALL THAT REMAINS OUT OF THAT
OVER THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED AND
SPENT BY THE COUNTIES.
IF YOU DIDN'T READ THE AUDIT OR
YOU'RE NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH THE
ACT ON EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
FUNDING THAT FLOWS TO COUNTIES.
IS DEDICATED TO COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES SAID THESE
ARE FOR DIRECT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH EITHER.
EARLY EMERGING OR.
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
IT IS NOT A MEANS TESTED A
FUNDING SOURCE SO AGAIN IN OUR
WORLD FROM THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WE SIT AND MEDICAID AS A MEANS
TESTED PROGRAM MEANING YOU HAVE
TO BE BELOW A CERTAIN INCOME
LEVEL. CLIP AGAIN THE
FLEXIBILITY.
AND SOME OF THE.
BENEFIT OF MHSAA IS THAT IT'S
NOT A MEANS TESTED FUNDING
SOURCE AND THAT COUNTIES CAN USE
THOSE FUNDS FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
THAT NEEDS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SO. WE WORK WITH
THE COUNTY'S QUITE CLOSELY TO
AND WHAT WE SAY BRAID FUNDING
TOGETHER MEANING THEY USE THAT
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS THEY USE
THEIR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OF
ACCOUNT DOLLARS THEY USE
MEDICAID MONEY. THEY USE MHSAA
DOLLARS ON TO. FULLY DELIVER
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS ON AND
THAT WAS REALLY WHAT THE PANEL
WAS TRYING TO SAY IS REGARDLESS
OF THE FUNDS SOURCE THEY'RE
TRYING TO DELIVER A. ENTIRE
PACKAGE BOTH BENEFIT AND SERVICE
INDIVIDUALS THAT REQUIRE IT. I'M
WE.
AGREE WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE
AUDITS FINDINGS ON THE TWO AREAS
THAT WE DISAGREED ON MORE
CERTAINLY NOTED IN OUR RESPONSES
AROUND.
REASONABLE AND PRUDENT RESERVES
AS WELL AS IN THE FISCAL
REGULATIONS I KNOW THAT.
.
WE HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE COUNTIES OVER WHAT.
A PRUDENT RESERVE SHOULD BE.
I THINK THAT YOU WILL AND. I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPINIONS AS TO WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE THE VOLATILITY
OF THE FUND ITSELF.
ANY TO SAY IS A TAX ON
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOMES OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS GIVEN THE WAY
THAT OUR CURRENT TAX STRUCTURE
IS AND HOW IT'S BASED ON CAPITAL
GAINS. THAT.
COLLECTION OF FUNDING IS QUITE
VOLATILE AS MOST OF THOSE STATES
OTHER AYE REVENUE SOURCES ARE
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE.
.
SEEN THE WHAT THE RECESSION DID
TO SOME OF THE COUNTIES IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY FUNDED. SERVICES AND
SO I THINK ARE.
INCLINATION IS TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
.
RISK AVERSE IN TERMS OF HOW THE
RESERVES ARE DEDICATED IS NOT IN
ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM OUR INTENT
TO HAVE COUNTY SITTING ON VAST
RESERVES WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
BE EXCESSIVE. BUT WE CERTAINLY
KNOW THAT IN TIMES OF DOWNTURN
ALL OF THE FUNDING STREAMS THAT
FLOW TO THE COUNTIES THE
REALIGNMENT ACCOUNT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ACCOUNT AND ME TO SAY.
THOSE ALL WAX AND WANE WITH THE
ECONOMY AND SO WE'RE.
EXTRAORDINARILY MINDFUL OF THE
FACT THAT IF THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNTURN I'M HAVING
A RESERVE THAT IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE GENEROUS THAN NOT.
COULD CERTAINLY BENEFIT THE
CITIZENS THAT ARE.
RELYING UPON THOSE FUNDS
SO.
WITH FAT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANSWER QUESTIONS ACTION OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH BEFORE WE. OPEN
IT TO QUESTIONS NOW I I'D LIKE
TO.
FIRST TO.
I INVITED W. INK FOR AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE SAID
IN COUNTERVAILING COMMISSION TO
ALSO GET COMMITTEE CHAIR MY
NAME'S W. AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MIDDLE SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION I WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR SETTING UP THIS
MEETING TODAY. AS WELL AS THE
AUDITOR AND HER STAFF FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY DID ON THE
REPORT.
THE COMMISSION INITIALLY
SUPPORTED.
SENATOR BELLS ASK TO THE
TENANTS HAD ABOUT A COMMITTEE
FOR THE AUDIT.
AND.
AND WE WERE INVITED TO COME AND
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND I'D HAD
ENVISIONED. THAT MIGHT BE THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY WHERE STATE
AGENCY WAS WAS POSITIVELY ASKING
TO BE AUDITED.
SO AND IT WAS A CONSENT ITEMS
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN BUT THE
COMMISSION WAS VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUDIT BECAUSE IT
FURTHERS THIS BROAD GOAL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AROUND THE EMMA TO SAY. AND AND
WE SEE THE CONVERSATION AS
CONTINUING.
THE WORK THAT THAT THE
COMMISSION HAD LAUNCHED STARTING
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
AND WE PROVIDED YOU A COPY OF A
REPORT THAT WE PROVIDE THAT WE.
PREPARED ON REVERSION.
WHICH BEGAN TO POINT OUT SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES IN IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RULES
AROUND REPORTING AND USE OF THE
FUNDS.
AND.
THE. THE AUDIT AS THE AUDITOR
SAID THERE WERE THREE CHALLENGES
IDENTIFIED IN TERMS OF THE
COMMISSION'S WORK AND AND WHERE
AGGRESSIVELY WORKING TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE ISSUES THE
FIRST WAS AROUND.
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT COUNTIES
AROUND INNOVATION AND AND SO I
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT WE
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS WE'VE
PROVIDED GREATER. CLARITY IN
TERMS OF MATERIALS WE'VE DONE
WHAT WE CALL A LITTLE A LITTLE
INNOVATION TOOL KIT THAT WE
PROVIDE TO THE COUNTIES THIS
MORNING I WAS. MEETING WITH.
THAT DETRACTED RELATES WITH THE
IMAGES TAKE COORDINATOR FOR THE
COUNTIES TO TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS OF THE COMMISSION IS
DOING TO STRENGTHEN THAT.
IN IN TERMS OF THAT THE BROAD
GOAL OF THE INNOVATION COMPONENT
OF THE KNOW HOW SERVICES ACT.
AND THEY WERE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT IS THAT IS IN FRONT OF YOU
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
IS THE COMMISSION IS PROPOSING
TO LAUNCH INNOVATION INCUBATOR
AS A STRATEGY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE COUNTIES
ONE OF THE ASIDE FROM THE ISSUE
OF PROCESS WHICH ALL GET INTO
BECAUSE IT CAME UP EARLIER. WITH
THE COMMISSION IS REALLY WORKING
TO STRENGTHEN THE ABILITY OF THE
COUNTIES TO LEARN COLLECTIVELY
AND THAT'S WHAT THE INNOVATION
DO IT IT IT'S A STRUCTURAL
FEATURE OF THE ACT THAT
RECOGNIZES. THAT THERE MANY
ASPECTS OF OUR SYSTEM THAT ARE
NOT AS WORKING AS WELL AS THEY
NEED TO BE AND SO IT'S A
MANDATE.
TO OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM TO
ACTUALLY TRY NEW THINGS.
TRYING NEW THINGS CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
IN FEBRUARY WE HOSTED AN
INNOVATION EVENT WITH THE TECH
SECTOR AND THAT AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS AND PROVIDERS
CONSUMERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
BROUGHT TO THE THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE. TRULY LOOK AT HUMAN
CENTERED DESIGN AS A STRATEGY TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT HOW WE.
HOW WE DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT A
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND THE PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF STATE ADMIN
FUNDS TO HELP US LAUNCH
INNOVATION INCUBATOR?
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ASKING THAT THE FOCUS ON EFFORTS
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CONSUMERS WHO END UP. DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
BECAUSE OF THE BACKLOG OF NEED
IN THE STATE HOSPITALS.
THE COMMISSION VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT WE'RE THRILLED AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THOSE FUNDS
TO REALLY IMPROVE THE PLANNING
SIDE IN THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CIDER AND INNOVATION. THE
QUESTIONS ALSO CONCERNED AROUND
INNOVATION OTHER AREAS AS WELL
PARTICULARLY STRATEGIES TO SERVE
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THE
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
PREVENTION OR INTERVENTION.
SO WE WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
AUDITOR TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN HOW WE HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT INNOVATION COMPONENT OF THE
ACT.
IN THE OF THE SECOND PIECE IS
ABOUT THE DATA THAT THE
COMMISSION BEGAN TO RECEIVE IN
DECEMBER AND SO IS THE AUDITOR
POINTED OUT THIS IS A BRAND NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THE DATA
BEGINNING TO ROLL AND WE
ABSOLUTELY WILL DEVELOP AN
ANALYTIC FRAMEWORK TO ANALYZE
THAT DATA BUT IT'S VERY EARLY IN
THE PROCESS NOT ALL COUNTIES
HAVE REPORTED IT'S A IT'S A NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. AND SO
WE'RE JUST NOT SURE WE CAN WE
CAN PUT THAT FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
IN THE TIME FRAME THAT THE
AUDITOR HAS RECOMMENDED BUT
WE'LL DO OUR BEST.
AND IN THE THIRD FINDING OF THE
AUDIT WAS THAT THE COMMISSION
MOVE FROM A LOCAL EVALUATION
STRATEGY FOR TRIAGE PROGRAMS TO
STATEWIDE STRATEGY. WHAT THAT
MEANS IS FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN THE
COMMISSION FIRST ISSUED FUNDING
FOR WHAT'S WHAT WE COLOR TRIAGE
PROGRAM WE REQUIRED EACH COUNTY
TO DESIGN AND EVALUATION INTO
THEIR PROPOSAL? THE INTENT WAS
TO ALLOW THE COUNTIES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THEIR PROGRAMS
WORKING FOR THEM. AND TO GIVE
THAT DETAILED NEW WANTS DAY THAT
WOULD HELP THEM STRENGTHENED
THEIR OWN PROGRAM.
AS THEY THOUGHT ABOUT A
STRATEGIES TO SUSTAIN THE
FUNDING ONCE THE GRANT DOLLARS
THAT WE PROVIDED TO THEM WERE
GONE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU DO THAT
REAL LOCAL NEW WANTS TO
VALUATION IT MAKES IT VERY HARD
TO TELL STATEWIDE STORY AND SO
THE COMMISSION HAS SHIFTED THE
STRATEGY. AND WERE MOVING TOWARD
THE STATE LEVEL EVALUATION TO
LOOK ACROSS THE COUNTY
INVESTMENTS WITH IT WITH THESE
TRIAGE DOLLARS INTO THAT THE
DECISION OF THE COMMISSION. MADE
IN NOVEMBER AND THAT'S VERY
ALIGNED WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE AUDITOR.
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
HEARD EARLIER WAS ABOUT THE
DELAYS IN SPENDING THE MONEY.
WHETHER OR NOT THE COMMISSION'S
PROCESS WAS WHAT PART OF THE
REASON WHY THEY'RE UNSPENT FUNDS
I THINK THE AUDITOR REPORTED
ABOUT SIXTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
END SPENT FUNDS HAS CURRENTLY
REPORTED BY THE DEPARTMENT IS
INNOVATION FUNDS. THE AUDITOR
ALSO FOUND THAT OUR PROCESS WAS
NOT LIKELY THE CAUSE FOR THAT
DELAY WE'VE APPROVED NINETY
THREEPERCENT OF THE PLANS THAT
COME BEFORE US. AND EIGHT OUT OF
TEN OF THOSE GET APPROVED WITHIN
ABOUT NINETY DAYS
AND THE REST TAKE A LITTLE MORE
TIMES AND HAS BECAUSE OF SOME
BACK AND FORTH.
SO.
YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
COUNTIES CAN BE FRUSTRATED WHEN
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THIS VERY
RIGOROUS PROCESS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEN IT COMES TO THE
COMMISSION. AND THE COMMISSION
RAISES CONCERNS PART OF THE GOAL
OF ESTABLISHING THIS INNOVATION
INCUBATOR IS TO STRENGTHEN THE
PROCESS AT THE FRONT END.
RATHER THAN.
HAVE THE COMMISSION'S
INVOLVEMENT AFTER ALL OF THAT
INVESTMENT HAS BEEN MADE
LOCALLY.
TO TRY TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
CONTINUES TO PRESERVE THE
ABILITY OF THE PROCESS TO BE
DRIVEN BY LOCAL PRIORITIES.
SO WORD WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IN THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN PLANNING SUPPORT
STRATEGY WILL ADDRESS MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES.
THE COUNTIES ARE FACING IN TERMS
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
PROPOSALS BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
THE COMMISSION'S ABILITY.
SUPPORT THEM ALONG THE WAY
RATHER THAN TO HAVE THAT CLASS
AFTER THEY'VE DONE THAT A
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENT IN LOCAL
PLANNING IN THE LOCAL
PRESENTATION THE APPROVAL BY THE
BOARD. AND THEN IT COMES BEFORE
A STATE BODY THAT THAT. THAT IS
NOT SATISFIED ACCORD OR DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE DIRECTION AT THE
HEADED AND. AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE
APPROVED NINETY THREE PERCENT OF
THE PLANS IN THAT IN THAT IN THE
WINDOW FROM I THINK THE END OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN THROUGH TO TODAY.
AND SO I THINK THE RECORD SHOWS
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE ACTUALLY.
ENGAGING THE COUNTIES WE CREATED
A PROCESS THAT'S PRETTY PRETTY
EFFICIENT PRETTY PRETTY QUICK
AND ACTUALLY DOES FOR THE MOST
PART RESULT IN APPROVALS WHEN
THE COMMISSION DOES TURN COUNTY
DOWN IT IT GIVES THE RIGHT
EXPLAINS THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
OR BUT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR. AND
RECOMMEND THAT THEY COME BACK
WITH A REVISED PROPOSAL
SOMETIMES THAT WORKS SOMETIMES
IT DOESN'T.
LASTLY I WOULD SAY THAT.
.
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF THINGS WE
GIVE ANYONE IS A IT'S A
DASHBOARD WHERE WE TRACK PLANS.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING REVIEW BY THE COMMISSION
YOU CAN SEE THOSE ARE IN THE
QUEUE. YOU CAN SEE THE ONES THAT
ARE BEING DEVELOPED AN AMOUNT OF
FUNDS AND THEIR SEVEN COUNTIES
THAT HAVE NOT PRESENTED IN ANY
INNOVATION PLANS BEFORE THE
COMMISSION SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
SO WE THINK THERE'S OF RANGE OF
REASONS WHY THE FUNDS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED AND IT'S IT'S. THERE'S
A LOT THAT WE CAN DO IN TERMS OF
OUR OWN INTERNAL PROCESS BUT
THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO IN TERMS
OF SUPPORTING THE BILL IF
COUNTIES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE FUNDS.
THE AM I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
TO OTHER THINGS ONE IS THAT IT'S
A SCREENSHOT OF OUR FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY TOOL THIS IS LIVE
ON OUR WEBSITE TODAY. IT ALLOWS
THE PUBLIC AND POLICYMAKERS TO
CLICK ON THEIR COUNTY AND
IDENTIFY THE REVENUES THAT THEY
RECEIVE FROM AND I JUST SAY OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS THE FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN SPENT. AND THE MONEY
THAT'S IN THE BANK AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE I
KNOW HOW SERVICES ACT REQUIRES
THE COUNTIES TO GO THROUGH A
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING TO
ESTABLISH TOOLS THAT SUPPORT
THAT PLANNING PROCESS AND
THERE'S THREE COMPONENTS AND SO
I'M SORRY MINE IS IN COLOR IT'S
MUCH NICER.
.
THE FIRST COMPONENT IS FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY.
AND SO THAT IS LIVE ON OUR SITE
TODAY.
THE SECOND COMPONENT IS AROUND
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
AND SO WE'RE WORKING TO DEVELOP
A TOOL WHERE YOU CAN CLICK ON
YOUR COUNTY AND SEE THE SERVICES
THAT ARE THAT ARE SUPPORTED WITH
THESE PUBLIC DOLLARS.
THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED INCLUDING INFORMATION ON
PEOPLE SERVED AND THE LAST PIECE
IS THE OUTCOMES
AND FOR OUTCOMES WERE BUILDING
OFF OF THE LANGUAGE THAT IS IN
THE ACT ALREADY.
THAT INCLUDES AMONG OTHER
OUTCOMES THINGS LIKE REDUCING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
SO WE HAVE A PRELIMINARY DATA
MATCH BETWEEN FSP DATA BETWEEN.
OF PEOPLE HER SIR BY FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS
HIGHEST AND HIGHEST LEVEL OF
COMMUNITY BASED CARE. AND WE'RE
LINKING THAT TO DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO BEGIN
TO DEVELOP SOME DATA AROUND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO DO BECOME
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVED. AND
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT
KINDS OF INVESTMENTS ACTUALLY
REDUCE THAT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT. OUR INTENT AND
IT'LL TAKE US IT'LL TAKE US
THREE TO FIVE YEARS IS WHAT
WE'VE SUGGESTED TO THE IN THE IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUDITOR. IS THAT THE PUBLIC WILL
BE ABLE TO CLICK ON A SINGLE
SITE AND SEE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. BECAUSE AGAIN
THIS IS ABOUT COMMITTEE PLANNING
PROCESS
TO SEE THE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM YOU HAVE AT THE MOMENT.
TO SEE WHO SERVED BY THAT SYSTEM
WHERE IT'S LOCATED
GEOGRAPHICALLY IN THE KIND OF
SERVICES THAT ARE OFFERED AND BE
ABLE TO CLICK ON YOUR COUNTY AND
OTHER COUNTIES. AND TO SEE
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SERVED OF THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIVERTED OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. WHO ARE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR ABILITY TO KEEP AND RETAIN
TO TO GET AND RETAIN A JOB? AND
NOW THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO
ARE PREVENTED FROM.
AB BEING REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME
TO CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
AND OTHER OUTCOMES THAT ARE THAT
ARE BOTH IN THE ACT AND
IMPORTANT TO CREATE THAT PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE BUT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP THIS CONVERSATION GOING.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU FELT ABOUT
WELL A.
FIRST.
I WANNA.
LET MY COLLEAGUES.
NO THAT.
WIN.
.
I RECALL THIS
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
WHEN.
.
DARRELL STEINBERG.
EVERYBODY TALKED TO ME ABOUT TO.
RUSTY SEALER X. OF COURSE AND
THE OTHERS TALKED ABOUT DOING
THE CAMPAIGN FOR. PROP SIXTY
THREE AND THEN WE.
.
WE STARTED CAMPAIGNING FOR AND
WE HAD.
FUND RAISERS AND ALL THE ALL
THE THINGS WE DID.
CAMPAIGN.
AND.
I DISTINCTLY REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT OF OUR.
.
COUNTY AND SANTA CLARA SMELL
HEALTH COMMISSION NOT A STRAW
MAN AND SHE. HER HUSBAND COURSES
LE ECONOMICS PROFESSOR AT SANTA
CLARA UNIVERSITY.
AND TALKING ABOUT.
.
WITH HIM.
รณ YOU GOTTA MAKE SURE THAT
MONEY SPENT JIM.
OKAY AND THERE WAS PROVISIONS AS
I'D NO NO NO NO THERE WAS A
PROVISION.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE WE TALKED
ABOUT IT.
DURING THE CAMPAIGN THERE WAS
PROVISION AND.
IN THE ACT.
IN THE ACT THAT WE PUT IN THERE
THAT.
IN THREE YEARS.
THE IF THEY DANCE MONDAY WAS A
USE IT OR LOSE IT.
PROVISION IN THE ACT.
THAT THE MONEY HAD TO BE SPENT.
IN THREE YEARS
AND WHAT THE REASON WAS FOR IT
WAS GOOD FISCAL MANAGEMENT FOR
THAT. THAT GOOD FISCAL
MANAGEMENT MEANING.
MENU HAD DISBANDED IN THREE
YOU KNOW CENTER MORE LIKE WOULD.
I DON'T KNOW.
IF IT GOES BEYOND IF THE BALANCE
IS GO BEYOND THREE YEARS PRETTY
SOON THEY GET LOST RIGHT.
IN THE IN.
COUNTY BUDGET LAND OR WHATEVER
PRETTY SOON THE MONEY.
KIND OF.
IT'S HARD TO TRACK IT BECOMES
HARDER AND HARDER TRAPPED.
AND IN FACT THE AUDITOR. HERE.
TALKED ABOUT.
GOING BACK.
SEVERAL YEARS AND THEY CAN'T
REALLY FIGURE OUT THIS STILL.
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE STILL.
TRYING TO TRACK OKAY.
SO.
THAT'S.
WE DON'T SHE WE'RE NOT REALLY
THERE'S NO DETENT DEFENDED OF.
AUDIT TRAIL YET.
IS NO DEFENDER OF AUDIT TRAIL
YET WE DON'T KNOW.
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON BUT
THAT'S WHAT A THREE YEAR THING
WAS PUT IN THERE OKAY.
WE PUT THAT THING IN THERE SO
WHEN WE WENT TO THE VOTERS.
WITH THIS.
TAX INCREASE.
YOU KNOW.
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW NOT.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THE MONEY
WAS USED.
IN THREE YEARS OR IT WASN'T.
IT HAD TO BE REVERTED.
SO THAT WERE THERE WOULD BE.
SOME KIND OF CONTROL ON THE
MONEY
OKAY.
SO WHEN WHEN.
.
WHEN I STARTED THIS PROCESS
FLEISCHER ACTUALLY DO BILL I DID
A BILL AND WENT THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE SO ALL WOMEN IT
YOU KNOW AND I SAID WELL WHAT IF
YOU KNOW. WHERE YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY GOT?
UPSET WHEN I DID THE BILL
BECAUSE I WAS TRYING TO DO
TRANSPARENCY BUILDING GOT
EVERYBODY. UPSET SO THEN I. I
SAID OH WILL WHY DON'T I JUST DO
AN AUDIT WILL FIND OUT WHAT THE
FACTS ARE FIRST.
BOTH FOR.
WE DO A BILL.
AND SO NOW WE HAVE THE ON IT
NOW.
THIS IS WHERE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW WE'RE AT THE POINT WHERE WE.
LOOK INTO IT WE HAVE THIS AUDIT.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THERE IS
THERE IS SOME.
EFFICIENCIES THAT WE HAVE TO
CORRECT.
WITH THIS EXPENDITURE MONEY.
WE HAD THE RIVERS AND THREE YEAR
ROLL AND IT'S NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED.
IT'S.
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH ALTHOUGH
THE STRUCTURE SO WE CAN DO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHO WE NEED TO DO AND
I THINK WERE RINGING NOW.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE DONE.
AND I WANT TO CORRECT.
ANYBODY THAT THINKS OTHERWISE WE
ARE CORRECTING THAT PROBLEM.
IS THAT NOT TRUE.
FOR THE PANELISTS.
NOBODY'S SAYING ANYTHING.
FOR THE RECORD WHERE CORRECTING
IT.
OKAY WE GOT THAT PROBLEM
CORRECTED.
SO I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE GETTING
THAT PROBLEM CORRECTED BECAUSE
WHEN I STARTED THAT PROCESS.
WELL LAST YEAR IT WAS LIKE WELL
WE DON'T WANT YOU KNOW WHEN NO
ONE IF WE DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
THIS JIM WE DON'T WANNA WE DON'T
WANNA.
GET A THIS IS A MESSY THINK SO
WE HAVE WE HAVE NOW A UNANSWERED
HERE WITH THIS AUDIT. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CORRECT IT.
THEN THERE'S THAT THEN THERE'S
THE PROCEDURES AND THE.
THE THE PROCESS FOR MAKING SURE.
LIKE I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WHEN
I HAD THAT.
.
DISCUSSION DURING THE CAMPAIGN
FOR PROP SIXTY THREE THAT THE
MONEY WAS GOING TO BE SPENT.
TIMELY.
AND WE HAVE A SENSE OF URGENCY.
ON THIS MONEY BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY.
I THINK THAT WE DON'T.
WE DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE PUBLIC
ACTUALLY GETS OF THE ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES?
SOMEBODY I SOMEONE STATES A
TWELVE PERCENT.
IT'S IS IS CREDIBLY LOW NUMBER.
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
RIDICULOUSLY LOW.
THAT THE ADEQUATE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND SO LIKE NOT SPENDING MONEY
ON THAT.
THAT.
PARTICULAR AREA.
AND HAVING ITS RESERVES.
IS TO ME KIND OF A MISTER
CHAIRMAN PRIVATE PROBLEM.
THEY'RE HAVING THIS RESERVES.
AND A AND AND IT'S KINDA LIKE
WE'RE NOT SPEND THE MONEY BUT WE
HAVE THIS URGENCY OKAY. SO I I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A ROBUST.
MAYBE DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE
RESERVE SHOULD BE WHAT.
LEVEL THAT. SHOULD BE THERE'S A
DIS.
THINK.
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ABOUT US.
NOW THE FIRST QUESTION WOULD BE
WHAT SHOULD THE RESERVE LEVEL
BE.
AND DO WE HAVE.
NORMALLY.
A RESERVE FOR.
OF FUND.
OR SHOULD WE NOT ESTABLISH
RESERVES.
FOR A COUNTY SHOULD THE COUNTY
NOT DETERMINE WHAT THE RESERVE
IS FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH.
PROGRAM.
SO IT USUALLY IS THAT YOU
ESTABLISH A RESERVE FOR.
THE PROGRAM IF IT'S AN ONGOING
PROGRAM.
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE MONEY
FROM ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
PLACES.
RATHER THAN JUST RESERVES FOR
THE OF PARTICULAR FUNDS SO.
WHAT WOULD THE OPINION OF PEOPLE
HERE THIS PANEL BE ABOUT WHAT
LEVEL RESERVE SHOULD WE HAVE?
AND THERE'S A DIFFERENCE WITH
THE AUDITOR CORRECT.
SO WE NEED OF GET THAT CLEARED
UP SO I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
WHAT RESERVE SHOULD WE HAVE FOR
THESE?
SO AND I THINK SENATOR THAT IS.
ONE OF THE KEY CRITICAL.
ITEMS THAT WERE WORKING THROUGH
AS BOTH THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE
AUDIT AS WELL AS.
WE TRY TO WORK IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH BOTH THE LA SEE
AS WELL AS THE COUNTIES.
SO WE HAVE AND WE HAD RETAINED
OUTSIDE.
EXPERTISE TO HELP US DETERMINE
THE LEVEL THAT WE HAD COME UP
WITH I THINK THE AUDITOR HAD A
DIFFERENT LEVEL I KNOW THAT THE
COUNTIES.
HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY WOULD PERCEIVE AS A
APPROPRIATE. AND IF PRUDENT
RESERVE AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
ANY OF US HAVE.
AS OF YET SAT DOWN AND COME TO
A MEETING OF THE MINDS I KNOW
THAT WE.
LIKE I SAID AND.
GIVEN THE VOLATILITY OF BOTH THE
FUND AND OUR OVERALL STATE
ECONOMY AND NOT WANTING TO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS LOSING SERVICE AT
THE SAME TIME WHEN THERE'S A
RECESSION I THINK WE. TEND TO BE
MORE.
CONSERVATIVE IN WANTING A
BIGGER RESERVE BUT I THINK. I'M
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN REACH
CONSENSUS WITH THE A COUNTIES ON
WHAT IS AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
RESERVE WE WOULD PUT THAT INTO
THE FISCAL REGULATIONSTHAT WE
ARE WORKING ON AS.
EVIDENCE STIR.
RECOMMENDED IN THE AUDIT
SOLUTION RECOMMENDATION ON
RESERVE IT'S BETWEEN SIXTY THREE
AND EIGHTY.
XTC THREE AND EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT OF THE ANNUAL ALLOCATION
THAT IT COUNTY RECEIVE SO TO
MAKE THE MATH EASY IF I GOT A
MILLION DOLLARS WE WOULD SAY YOU
NEED TO HAVE. BETWEEN SIX
HUNDRED ANDTHIRTY OR SIX
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND AND
EIGHTY THREE YEAR INTERN THIRTY
THOUSAND.
IN A RESERVE.
YOU KNOW THAT YOU WOULD NEED TO
HOLD ONTO SAID MAKE THE MATTER
NIGHT OF. PERHAPS IF I CAN HAVE
THE STATE AUDITOR.
GIVE THEIR RECOMMENDATION.
WHAT WAS THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WE GET I JUST
TO?
GIVE THE RANGE OF THE DIFFERENCE
IF I COULD MET MISTER CHAIRMAN
SHORT QUESTION.
WHAT WHAT LEVEL WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMEND BASED ON THEIR
STUDY?
FOR A RESERVE.
SO I CAN THINK OF THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE RECORD JOHN
BUYER THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE.
WE WE LOOKED AT THE FLUCTUATION
AND IN THE MIDDLE SERVICES
REVENUES FROM YEAR TO YEAR OVER
THE PAST TEN YEAR PERIOD. AND WE
LOOKED AT THAT THE LARGEST
DECLINE IN ANY ONE YEAR AS THAT
THE AS LIKELY THEM THE MOST I
RESERVE COULD BE. THAT LARGEST
DECLINE IN ANY ONE YEAR WAS
THIRTY THREE PERCENT.
THE IN THE END THE AVERAGE OF
THOSE DECLINES OVER THAT TEN
YEAR PERIOD UP OF THE CLIENTS
THEMSELVES.
WAS TWENTY THREE PERCENT SWEET
WE PAID A RANGE BETWEEN TWENTY
THREE. PERCENT AND THIRTY THREE
PERCENT.
OKAY SO.
SO YOU HAD A MILLION DOLLARS HOW
MUCH WOULD THAT BE COMPLETELY
DEALER TO WHAT A TWO. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE THOUSAND OR
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND.
DELEGATES THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN
SEE THE DIFFERENCE.
OKAY IT START THINK I THINK I'M
THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT THIS IS
A KEY DISCUSSION.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT RESERVE
LEVELS SHOULD BE.
AND WHAT I'D LIKE JUST ADD
SENATOR IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DISCUSSED IN THE REPORT
THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS
AT MONEY THAT'S PUT INTO RESERVE
IS NOT NECESSARILY SUBJECT TO
REVERSION.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT. A LOCAL
ENTITIES ARE PUTTING MONEY INTO
RESERVE AND NOT SPENDING IT THAT
MONEY IS NOT GONNA REVERT BACK
TO THE STATE FOR REALLOCATION TO
OTHER COUNTIES. THE OTHER THING
WE IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT IS
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FIFTY NINE
ENTITIES THAT HAVE.
.
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING IS
PROGRAM WE WE IDENTIFIED FORTY
SIX.
THAT DID NOT HAVE FUNDS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
REVERSION.
BACK IN OF AT THE END OF TWENTY
SIX
STEAM DOT FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SO THERE ARE COUNTIES
AND ENTITIES OUT THERE. THAT ARE
USING THESE FUNDS COULD USE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO THE REASON
WE THINK HAVING THE APPROPRIATE
RESERVE AMOUNT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IS. SO THERE IS AN
EXCESSIVE RESERVES AT CERTAIN
COUNTIES WERE OTHER COUNTIES
COULD USE THOSE FUNDS TO GET.
OUR MONEY OUT THERE AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR INDIVIDUALS IN
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE.
SO THAT'S WHY WE DID AN ANALYSIS
WE THOUGHT IT WAS FAIR LOOKING
AT A TEN YEAR WINDOW. ARE AND
SAYING WHAT WAS THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO OVER THOSE TEN YEARS AS
MR BUYER INDICATORS ABOUT THIRTY
THREE PERCENT.
SO WE SAID BASED ON THIRTY THREE
PERCENT HOW MUCH OF A TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION.
WOULD HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE.
AND IT WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION BECAUSE THERE'S
FIVE AND THIRTY FIVE AND
RESERVES.
THERE WERE ABOUT ABOUT ANOTHER
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD OF
RE ALLOCATED TO THOSE FORTY SIX
COUNTIES. THE DIDN'T HAVE MONEY
THAT WAS SUBJECT TO REVERSION TO
THE EXTENT THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE SERVICES SO
THIS IS AS YOU INDICATED.
A CRITICAL ISSUE THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO NEEDS TO RESOLVE SO IF
I ESTABLISHED AND INVITE COULD
MISTER TERRIFIED ESTABLISH A
RESERVE.
A RESERVE I SAID OKAY EACH.
IS THE RESERVE FOR EACH COUNTY
OR IS IT A STATEWIDE RESERVE.
YOU'D BE A RESERVE LEVELS AT
EACH COUNTY WOULD WOULD USE
WOULD FALL SOVIET STEPS TO
RESERVE LEVEL THIRTY THREE
PERCENT.
EACH COUNTY COULD HAVE UP TO
THIRTY THREE PERCENT OF ITS
PRIOR YEAR REVENUES IN THAT OF
THAT ERICA.
AND SO IF IT WAS A THIRTY THREE
PERCENT LEVEL.
THAT.
SAY.
I PUT THE MONEY IN.
SAY HAVE A GOOD YEAR AND THERE'S
A LOT OF.
LOT OF MILLIONAIRES THAT WE CAN
TAX AND.
WHATEVER YOU KNOW WE TAX AND
I'M.
AND THAT A YOU CAN PUT ALL THE
MONEY IN A GOOD YEAR YOU CAN PUT
THE MONEY INTO RESERVE.
THAT RESERVE WILL STAY THERE.
AND IF THE REVENUE DECLINES IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS YOU STILL
HAVE THAT RESERVE IN AN ACCOUNT
RIGHT THAT MY CORRECT.
SO SO.
.
IS NOT AN ANNUAL AMOUNT YOU HAVE
TO SET ASIDE IT IT'S NOT IT JUST
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T SPEND IT OF
COURSE GREG.
IT'S LIKE A RAINY DAY FUND KIND
OF THING.
LIKE WE HAVE IN OUR BUDGET
REQUIREMENT BUDGET REQUIRES US
TO HAVE A.
RAINY DAY FUND BUT THIS IS.
.
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SPEND
MONEY ON PROGRAMS.
NOW IF YOU HAD.
.
IF YOU LOOK AT OVER FIVE YEARS.
AND YOU SAY OKAY HERE'S HOW MUCH
MONEY WE'RE GONNA SPEND OVER
FIVE YEARS.
AND FOR FIVE STRAIGHT YEARS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THE USE OF
THAT RESERVE.
HOW MUCH?
?
OF THE.
FIVE YEAR ALLOCATION WOULD BE.
USED FOR RESERVE.
IT WON'T BE A A WOULD BE THAT
MUCH CORRECT.
BUT IF.
YEAH IF. IF THERE WAS NO NEED TO
DRAW DOWN THE RESERVE TO IF YOU
QUITE YEAH YES IF YOUR QUESTION
IS THAT. THAT THEIR REVENUES
WERE SUFFICIENT AND ALL FIVE
YEARS OVER IT FOR FOR THE PLAN
FOR THE FOUR OF THEM BY THE
PROGRAM IN THE FUNDING THAT YOU.
HAD PLANNED FOR THEN YOU
WOULDN'T NEED TO TOUCH THOSE
RESERVES THEY WOULD STAY THERE.
NOW THE COUNTY'S.
DON'T TO SPEND THAT MONEY ON
ONGOING SERVICES THEY SPEND IT
ON ONE TIME SERVICES AS WELL
RIGHT.
CORRECT THERE'S MONEY SPENT ON
CAPITOL OTHER KINDS OF.
AND IF YOU HAD A BAD YEAR YOU
JUST DON'T SPEND THE MONEY ON A
CAPITAL PROJECT BUT YOU CAN
CONTINUE SPENDING.
MONEY ON THE A ONGOING PROJECT
IS THAT CORRECT.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER WAY OF
REDUCING YOUR EXPENDITURES BY.
DEFERRING OR SPREADING OUT THE
COST OF THE.
CITY A CAPITAL PROJECT THAT YOU
WANT TO SPEND THE MONEY ON.
WHATEVER I DON'T KNOW WE'D HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE LIST OF CAPITAL
PROJECTS.
SO IS THERE ANOTHER WAY TO
REGULATE THE FLOW OF THE CASH.
AND PROTECT A RESERVE. IT IT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE.
OKAY SO OUT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK.
I THINK.
.
THE RESERVE. POLICY.
TO ME IT'S ONE OF THE CENTRAL
POINTS OF THIS AUDIT.
AND AND AND BECAUSE IF WE SET
THE RESERVE TO HIGH.
IT WILL RESULT IN MONEY THAT THE
VOTERS APPROVED.
NOT BEING SPENT ON THE PURPOSE
OF WHICH THE VOTERS DECIDE AND
WHAT THE MONEY FOR.
SO THAT'S.
TO MEET TO ME THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT REAL REAL THING.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS ABOUT SETTING THE
RESERVE.
TOO HIGH.
AND I THINK THERE HAS TO BE
POLICIES A BACKUP TO RESERVE AND
BACK UP THE EXPENDITURES AND
THOSE POLICIES RECOMMENDED BY
THE AUTHOR I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT AGREED TO THOSE RIGHT
IS THAT CORRECT.
SO NOW WE WE DISAGREE ON THE
AMOUNT OF THE RESERVE BUT I
THINK I WAS I WAS ONE AREA BUT
NO OTHER AREAS THERE WASN'T TOO
MANY OTHERS YOU DISAGREED WITH
RIGHT.
NO THE TIMING OF THE FISCAL
REGULATIONS SO THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE OF.
BETWEEN US BUT. AND TO AND THEN.
AND THEN WE HAD SOME
CLARIFICATION ON A FORMER
APPROPRIATION.
THAT WAS I STILL A CARRYOVER
WITH THE STING OF LITTLE ENOUGH
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS YEAH
IT'S. LIKE HAVING A.
.
AND THIS IS MY NON
SCHOOL WAY OF EXPLAINING AT IS
LIKE HAVING AN OPEN CHECKING
ACCOUNT WITH NO MONEY IN THE
ACCOUNT SO THE. THAT IT LOOKED
LIKE THERE WAS A TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE APPROPRIATION BUT
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATION LIMIT
BUT THERE WAS ACTION NUMB MONEY
IN THE ACCOUNT SO. OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WORK WITH
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS
CLOSE DOWN BUT YOU KNOW THERE
WAS NO ACTUAL MONEY IN THE
ACCOUNT. KNOW THERE STILL EXISTS
DISAGREEMENT IT IF I MODEL
AIRPLANE ON. THE TOWARD WILL
HARDLY THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
SENT CENTER FROM A CLARIFY AT.
THE AT THAT CONCLUSION THE AUDIT
THE DEPARTMENT DID DID SHOW US
THAT A DOCUMENT THAT THE THAT
THE CONTROLLER HAD ADJUSTED THE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND HAVE THAT
AMENDMENT SITTING THERE FOR FOR
OVER FIVE YEARS THE DEPARTMENT
STAFFER WE SIMPLY RECONCILE
BETWEEN THEIR RECORDS AND THOSE
THE STATE CONTROLLER SAYING THAT
THE MONEY EXISTED. IT'D BEEN
SHOWING UP IN THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS FOR THAT
FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
OUR REVIEW IDENTIFIED THE AMOUNT
OF WHEN WE ASK THE DEPARTMENT
WHY THE STATE COMPTROLLER JUST
OF THAT AMOUNT OUT.
THAT HARPER COULDN'T PROVIDE US
AN ANSWER WE ASKED FOR A CONTACT
NAME OF THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THAT WE CAN TALK TO. THAT
HARM WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
AND AN ANSWER AND THIS WASN'T
JUST ABOUT ANYWHERE IN YOUR FALL
OF RESPONSIBILITY WHEN YOU WRITE
FOLLOW UP THE AUDIT YOU GO KEEP
WORKING ON THAT TO YOU.
YOU REACH A DEAD END OUR GUESTS
YOU WANT TO SET THAT WAY. RIGHT
AND SEWER AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE AT THE SIX TODAY
RESPONSE OF WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN SHOW US. THAT THE ADJUSTMENT
WAS CORRECT TO DO.
OKAY THANK YOU CLOSE FAMILY.
SARAH MARLA.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR THIS
MORNING THERE WAS AN ARTICLE.
OF THAT FOLLOWED UP ON IT WOULD
TIMES.
COLUMN BY THE BUSINESS PAGE
COLUMNIST.
.
THAT CALPERS AND HIRED A NEW CFO
THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
RESUME AND THEREFORE YOU SHOULD
CONTACT THE MEMBERS OF THE.
I PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PANTS INNER MORAL I CAN
SO. I AM SO EVERYBODY SORT OF
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
ON A COMMITTEE THEN YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING. THE
WHOLE SHOW AND SO.
THAT'S THE KIND OF LIFE WERE
LIVING AS LEGISLATORS.
SOME IS CAN IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
HERE TODAY ACT I.
.
I YOU KNOW WE DON'T GET MUCH
CHANCE WERE WERE LEGISLATORS
THAT EXECUTIVES BUT WERE SOMEHOW
HELL TO AN EXECUTIVE.
SOMEHOW RESPONSIBILITY SO
GOVERNMENT KIND OF FUN.
HAVING BEEN HERE IN THIS ARENA
FOR TWO DECADES I CAME OUT OF
THE PRIVATE SECTOR'S APARTMENT
CPA FIRM SO I GET. YOU KNOW I
COULD WRITE THE CHECKS AND I
COULD YOU KNOW DO EVERYTHING
RIGHT AWAY.
SO.
YOU KNOW YOU SEE IT SO YOUR
YOUR YOUR REALIZE YOU'RE IN A
NON COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT SO
THERE'S MAYBE NOT. A I'LL A
REASON LOOK OVER YOUR SHOULDERS
TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING'S GOING
AS QUICKLY TO PROBABLY AS AS
YOUR COMPETITORS ARE GOING. BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE SENSE OF BEING
A TEAM BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO
PICK ON EACH OTHER WHEN THINGS
OR DISCOVERED WHEN IT'S TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. IMPROVE
THINGS SO THAT WITH THIS THIS
FUND BALANCE WE'VE HAD.
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE YOU KNOW
APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR SO
WE ARE TALKING MORE THAN A
DECADE AGO. ARE THAT IT WAS
APPROVED AND AND NOW I GET THIS
REPORT AND.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT IT'S NOT
PLEASANT IT SAYS DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES WITH REGARDS
TO OVERSIGHT. WORDS LIKE
INEFFECTIVE AND.
MINIMAL AND IN I GO THROUGH THE
KEY FINDINGS AND HAS NOT.
PROVIDED EFFECTIVE DIRECTION NOT
DEVELOP THE PROCESS FOR
RECOVERING FUNDS.
I HAD NO GUIDANCE IN HOW LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY SHOULD
TREAT INTEREST.
INADEQUATELY OVERSEAS THE FUNDS.
THAT LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES RECEIVE IT HAS I'VE
FORCED REPORTING TAKE QUITE
DEADLINES MUSES. THAT IS
FRUSTRATING AS A AS A. AN
EXECUTIVE LEGISLATOR AND I'M.
I'M I'M I'M JUST WANNA KNOW YOU
KNOW THE COUNTY WOULD START
IMPLEMENTING MAJOR STRUCTURAL
CHANGES WHAT. WHAT ARE WE DOING
AT THE STATE LEVEL WHAT WE DO IS
A HATE?
WE WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT THIS IT'S
THE TIME MAYBE THIRD TIME.
WHAT WE DO AT YOUR LEVEL TO?
IT SURE THAT TAXPAYERS WITH
SPECIAL THE ONES ARE PAYING.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A MILLION
DOLLARS OF TAXABLE INCOME.
NOT THEIR MONEY IS BEING USED.
IT'S YOU KNOW APPROPRIATELY WHAT
I THOUGHT. I'M HERE THIS IS THE
MOMENT IN TIME I JUST LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT HEAD.
WHAT DO YOU DO WHAT'S GOING ON
IN?
SURE SO AND YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF
THINGS AND SO WE HAVE A. LOT OF
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE SINCE
WE.
TOOK OVER THE OVERSIGHT.
SO THIS WAS A DEPARTMENTS.
FUNCTION THAT CAME TO US IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE.
AND IT HAS CHANGED A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT TIMES RIGHT THE
INITIATIVE AS IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PASSED BY THE VOTERS HAS BEEN
MODIFIED. A COUPLE TIMES UNDER
THE FORMER DEPARTMENT THAT
ADMINISTERED IT IT USED TO BE
THAT THE STATE HELD THE FUNDS
AND THE COUNTY HAD TO COME.
AND GET THE FUNDS ALLOCATED TO
IT AND THEN THERE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT.
SEVERAL YEARS AFTER THAT WHERE
THE COUNTY SAID THIS IS.
NOT AS FLEXIBLE AS WE NEED IT
TO BE INSIDE THE INITIATIVE WAS
CHANGED TO SAY THE FUNDS FUND
FROM THE TAX
GO STRAIGHT TO THE COUNTIES AND
THEN THERE WAS AN OVERSIGHT.
CHANGE I AM I THINK YOU KNOW YOU
SAY IT.
REALLY WELL AND THAT WE HAVE A
REALLY BIG DEPARTMENT ITH A LOT
OF COMPLICATED.
PIECES A LOT OF.
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS BOTH AT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL WE
WELCOME.
OVERSIGHT I WILL ALWAYS SAY
THAT THERE IS ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT BOTH IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA AS WELL AS IN
OTHER PARTS OF OUR DEPARTMENT.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN.
.
WORKING REALLY DILIGENTLY WITH
THE COUNTIES TO ISSUE GUIDANCE
ON BOTH THE PROGRAMMATIC.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS.
ACT AS WELL AS OTHER PIECES OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM SO I I JUST WANT TO.
REMIND YOU THAT. THAT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT IS ONE
COMPONENT OF A MUCH BROADER
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM SO
WHEN WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES AROUND GUIDANCE WERE
NOT ONLY LOOKING TO THEM AROUND
MHSAA BUT WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH THEM AS IT PERTAINS TO MEDI
CAL. BOTH PEDIATRIC AND ADULT
POPULATIONS AND SO I THINK THESE
REGULATIONS HAVE TAKEN AWHILE
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER. KIND OF
FUN PRESSING EITHER ISSUES THERE
HAVE BEEN OTHER.
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH THE
COUNTIES AROUND RECONCILIATIONS
AND SO I JUST.
I'M NOT MAKING.
NECESSARILY EXCUSES I'M JUST
SAYING IT IS A REALLY BIG.
COMPLEMENT IN WHICH WE WORK.
YOU KNOW REALLY WELL WITH FIFTY
SIX DIFFERENT COUNTIES BUT WE
WORKED FIFTY SIX DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND SO I THINK THE
AUDIT RAISED.
FAIR POINTS WE ACKNOWLEDGED
WHAT THOSE ARE WE ARE WORKING TO
MEET THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE.
I AGREE WITH THEM IN THE AUDIT
AND I THINK.
EITHER THE ONLY AT THE LAST
THING I WOULD SAY IS WE ALSO
GIVEN LIMITED RESOURCES WITHIN A
STATE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE. YOU'LL
NEVER HAVE AND YOU KNOW THIS
COMING FROM AYE AYE COUNTY
THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO DO. A WHOLE HUNDRED
PERCENT AND SO WE ALSO TRY TO
TARGET OUR LIMITED RESOURCES TO
THE AREAS THAT WE THINK. ARE
HIGHEST RISK.
IMAGE TO SAY.
THERE HAS NOT EVER BEEN AN
ALLEGATION WHERE THE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED INAPPROPRIATELY AND SO
I REALLY WANT TO STRESS THAT AS
WELL IS THAT WE ARE IN A PLACE
WHERE THE COUNTIES. HAVE NOT
USED FUNDS.
AS QUICKLY AS WE WANTED THEM TO
WE ARE WORKING TO SOLVE THAT.
BUT I THINK WE ALSO AS A
DEPARTMENT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PROGRAM
INTEGRITY WE HAVE ALSO FOCUSED
IN AREAS WHERE WE HAD OTHER MORE
HIGHER PRIORITY ISSUES AROUND
PROGRAM INTEGRITY SO I JUST. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE NOT AN
EXECUTIVE AS YOU STATED I'M.
I HAVE I WORK WITH AS MUCH AS
I'M CAPACITY AS I HAVE AT THE
TIME AND WE TARGET THE HIGHEST
EITHER NEED OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY
AND THIS IS DEFINITELY. A
PRIORITY BUT IT CERTAINLY HAS.
HAD A LOT OF DIFFERENT IMPACTS
ON IT AS THE YEARS HAVE.
.
AS WE HAVE HAD IT SINCE IT CAME
TO US IN TWENTY TWELVE
SO PROP SIXTY THREE DID IT A
PROVIDE A AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPONENT. STRIKE ONE PERCENT OR
TWO PERCENT OR FIVE PERCENT OF
THE MONEY WILL BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATION THAT'S RIGHT. SO
THEN WHO DO YOU HAVE A MHSAA
DIRECTOR THAT OVERSEES THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES NO SO I HAVE
GOING ON.
NEW.
I'M HAVING TROUBLE WITH YOUR
RIGHT RESPONSE AND WE HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE RESOURCE RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE.
WE HAVE RECEIVE STAFF IN THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME TO DO PROGRAM
AUDITS SO THOSE POSITIONS CAME
TO US LAST YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO THAT WAS
THE FIRST TIME WE HAD.
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO.
LOOK AT THE PROGRAMMATIC
FUNCTIONS OF MHSAA WE HAVE.
MAYBE TWELVE OR THIRTEEN STAFF
TOTAL THAT OUR IMAGE IT'S A
FUNDED WITHIN A DEPARTMENT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. AND THEN
WHAT WE DO IS WE HAVE STAFF THAT
HANDLE MULTIPLE COMPONENTS THAT
ARE NOT JUST MHSAA.
SPECIFIC SO I HAVE CERTAIN
FISCAL EXPERTS THAT NOT ONLY
HELP ON THE EPS DUTY AND SO WE
USE.
STAFF ACROSS MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
BUT SPECIFICALLY FUNDED ON MHSAA
IT'S A FAIRLY SMALL NUMBER OF
STAFF AND THAT'S PUBLIC TWELVE
OR THIRTEEN AND A DEPARTMENT OF
FOR THOUSANDS.
BUT THAT'S A KEY FUNDING SOURCE
AND IT WOULDN'T BE A KEY MANAGER
AND YOURS. ORG CHART.
WELL IT'S A IT'S A FUNDING
SOURCE IN MY DEPARTMENT IT'S
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN A.
STATEWIDE OPERATIONS BUDGET OF
OVER SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
BUT YOU HAVE AN EXPENDITURE HAD
THE RESOURCES THAT. I'M HAVING
TROUBLE DEAR DIGESTING THAT SO
SO YOU'VE HAD IT FOR A FEW YEARS
WHERE IS THE STRATEGIC PLAN.
SO WHEN YOU SAY SO WE SO THE SO
THE INITIATIVE DOESN'T CALL
NECESSARILY FOR US TO HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN I THINK WE WORK
WITH THE COMMISSION IN TERMS OF.
HELPING SET POLICY AROUND WHAT
THE COUNTIES CAN USE THEIR MHSAA
FUNDING FOR BUT THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
ME TO SAY THAT WE AS A
DEPARTMENT ARE.
EITHER CHARGED WITH I THINK
THAT.
WE WORK.
BOTH WITH LEGISLATORS AND
OTHERS TO HELP SET.
GUIDANCE AROUND CERTAIN
INITIATIVES BUT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT WE HAVE.
SO.
A MY WORDS. IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE
GOT.
A COMPONENT OF YOUR OPERATION
THAT SORTA LIKE A RENTAL IS BOAT
WHICH IS KINDA JUST.
FLOATING THERE AND I'M.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOW
THAT EVEN HAPPENS.
I'M
SO THERE'S BEEN THIS CONCERN
ABOUT LACK OF LEADERSHIP.
SO.
IT THAT'S I GUESS MY LAST
QUESTION MR CHARITY. WHY DO WE
HAVE TO DO LEGISLATION TO TELL
YOU TO FIND A LEADER AND TO DO A
STRATEGIC PLAN WHY ISN'T THAT
JUST?
YOU KNOW DEBT JUST COMES FROM
MANAGEMENT WHAT AND WHY IS THAT
JUST.
WISEMAN BEEN THERE.
SO A COUPLE THINGS.
I THINK THAT IT'S IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER TO BE RUDDERLESS I
WOULD CHALLENGE THAT JUST A
LITTLE BIT FROM THE STANDPOINT
THAT WE HAVE.
HAD PROGRAMMATIC GUIDANCE OUT TO
THE COUNTIES.
ON THE IMAGE TO SAY FUNDING WE
HAVE AYE REGULATIONS WE HAVE
CERTAIN GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
.
I THINK WHAT WE ALSO.
THERE'S A CAREFUL BALANCE
BECAUSE THE INITIATIVE.
AS WAS MENTIONED IN A PREVIOUS
PANEL IT WAS INTENDED AND
CAREFULLY CRAFTED TO MAKE IT A
LOCAL DECISION.
A LOCALLY APPROVED AND THE
LOCALLY DETERMINES
ALLOCATION PROCESS SO I THINK
THAT THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
INHERENT TENSION.
BETWEEN.
THE STATE AND THE COUNTIES FOR
WHICH THEY ARE.
SETTING THEIR OWN BUDGETS
THEY'RE WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE WORKING
WITH THEIR PLANNING. COUNCILS
ARE WORKING WITH THEIR LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND IT IS A GROUND
UP EXPENDITURE AND A AND A
GROUND UP.
.
DRIVEN MECHANISM AND SO I THINK
WE ARE NOT AS THE STATE
AUTHORIZED OR OTHERWISE ALLOWED
TO COME IN AND SO THAT'S ALSO
BEEN ATTENTION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRY WE'VE TRIED TO BE RESPECTFUL
I THINK OF HOW THE INITIATIVE
WAS DRAFTED AND WE DO NOT.
EXCEED OUR THIRTY I'M IN AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE NOT BEEN OTHERWISE
AUTHORIZED I THINK THAT'S ALSO
WHAT WE TRY TO BE MINDFUL THAT.
JANET NGUYEN CLOSING.
WE HAVE A STATE LIBRARIAN AND I
SEE HIM ALL OVER THE STATE.
HELPING COUNTIES
WITH THEIR LIBRARIES I I WOULD
SAY THAT YOU MIGHT WANNA LOOK AT
THAT MODEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS CAMP
THANK YOU MISTER.
THEN SOMEONE MONROVIA HIGH AT
THANK YOU TOM AYE EXCEEDS WHAT
FOLLOW UP ON SOMETHING THAT.
SIR BELL SAID SO ABOUT THE
RESERVE.
AND SO IS HE RELAYED HISTORY OF
THE INITIATIVE HE SAID DEL THE
ATTENTION VERY MUCH WAS THAT. WE
WILL GET THE MONEY OUT IF YOU
DON'T.
THERE'S BEEN ACTUALLY ALLOCATING
GET THE MONEY OUT THIS GUY REFER
TO AND.
BE ADDED RETURN TO THE POLL WE
GET THAT OUT.
THAT I WOULD HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU DESERVE BUT
THE PART THE PART OF THE
QUESTION THAT I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON THAT HE BROUGHT UP IS IS
THAT.
SHOULD THE RESERVE. BE.
JUST A RESERVE FOR EACH COUNTY
OR SHOULD IT BE SPECIFICALLY
ALLOCATED TO SPECIFIC PROJECTS
BECAUSE I CAN SEE YES WITH A
VAULT HOUSE.
UP AND DOWN. THAT IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO SUSTAIN A CERTAIN
LEVEL FUNDING FOR A PROJECT YOU
MAY NEED A RESERVE FOR A PROJECT
BUT JUST TO HOLD THE MONEY INTO
A POT.
AND NOT ACTUALLY HAVE IT
ALLOCATED AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
IF THE TENSION THREE YEARS THEN
WITHIN THREE YEARS YOU GAIN THE
MONEY YOU NEED TO SIGN AT THE
SOMETHING.
AND MAYBE A ROUTE YOU KNOW MAY
NOT BE SEATS THAT'S RIGHT SENT
OUT RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
TRYING TO YOU BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT'S VOLATILE YOU TRY BUT. AT
LEAST YOU'RE DESIGNATING IT FOR
SOMETHING YOU'RE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON.
BUT.
PERHAPS MAKE SOME SENSE.
IN TERMS OF JUST AS THEY'RE
SAYING WE HAVE A RESERVIST
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF.
ALL THE MONEY WE THAT IS JUST IN
THIS GENERIC POT THAT IS ALL
THAT FITS PROP SIXTY THREE WE
CAN JUST HOLD ITS CASH AND YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT YOU DECIDE WE
WILL SPEND IT ON.
WITHIN THOSE A THREE APPEARED
OF YOU RECEIVING AT.
SO I AS I'M HEARING THE HISTORY
PERHAPS SOME WEAKENED PERHAPS WE
CAN GET THE COMMENT FROM THE
AUDITOR'S AND THAT I MAY SAY AND
AND AND BE EIGHT CS ABOUT SAYING
THAT IF YOU GOT IMPORTANT IF YOU
GO PUT MONEY AWAY.
NOW YOU HAVE THREE YEARS DECIDED
WHAT YOU'RE PUTTING IN A WAY FOR
INSIDIOUS LEVY AND SOME GENERIC
ACCOUNT POOL SAYS.
PROP SIXTY THREE WHATEVER WE
DECIDE YEARS LATER ON THAT WE
WANT TO SPEND IT ON LATER.
IT'S THAT SAYING THAT INTENT IS
IS THAT SPEND IT DESIGNATED AND
I GET THE IDEA IS NOW THE BIG
THE DATED THEN YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
AN INTENTION WE'VE SPENDING IT
ON.
SO BECAUSE HE BROUGHT THAT UP
EARLIER YELLS IT AND PUT IT FOR
SPECIFIC PROGRAMMERS EFFORT.
GENERICALLY FOR JUST IN A POT.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENN HAD TO BE
DOING WITH THE COMMISSION.
.
S. HAS THE SENATOR SAID THE
INTENT OF THE ACT WAS TO INFUSE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO MEET UNMET
NEEDS RIGHT AT THE VERY VERY
CLEARLY THE INTENT IS TO MAKE
FUNDS AVAILABLE TO BE SPENT.
RIGHT
IT'S ALSO RECOGNITION THAT.
.
THAT COUNTIES CAN AND SHOULD SET
ASIDE AN AMOUNT FOR PRUDENT
TRIED AND SO YOU'RE GETTING AT
THE ISSUE OF WHAT'S A PRINT
LEVEL.
I THINK THE KEY IN THE
COMMISSION IS I'M NOT
APPROACHING THIS FROM FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT'S THE RIGHT
PERCENT TRY THE COMMISSION
REALLY FOCUSED ON THIS HAVE. YOU
KNOW IS THIS A DECISION THAT
COMPETITIVE MUNITY HAS ACTUALLY
INFORMED AND MAY RIGHT TO THE
EXTENT THAT. THEY TAKE A COUNTY
IS DECIDING NOT TO SPEND FUNDS.
TO WITH HOLD THEM FOR FUTURE
USES IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE DYING IN THE STREETS.
THEN RIGHT THEN THAT'S A
DECISION THAT THE OTHER THE
QUESTION HERE IS WHAT WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSING ON THIS FRONT A
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY RIGHT AND THERE MAY
BE SOME COUNTIES. THAT THROUGH
ALL THIS PROCES THEY'VE DECIDED
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE I DON'T
THINK THAT BE THE CHOICE THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO COUNTY TO MAKE.
THEM AT BUT WE'VE REALLY TRIED
TO FOCUS ON IN SO THE INFORMED
CONSENT
SIDE OF THE DECISION AROUND WHAT
IS PRUDENT FORBES ARE FORGIVEN
COUNTY.
THE REASON THAT THE WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING IS ACTUALLY VERY
CHALLENGING.
IS THAT THE MHS SAY IS ABOUT
TWENTY TO THIRTY PERCENT
OF OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS
IN A GIVEN YEAR BUT IN SOME
COUNTIES THAT MAKES UP FORTY TWO
OR FORTY FIVE OR EVEN FIFTY
PERCENT.
RIGHT AND THE FUNDS ARE REALLY
BLENDED AND SO THERE MAY BE SOME
PROJECTS
WHERE YOU COULD SET ASIDE A
PORTION OF DOLLARS FOR RESERVE.
BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
THE MONEY IS BLENDED TO REALLY
TRACK THE DOLLARS SEPARATE FROM
YOUR OVERALL SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY
I THINK THAT. THE SORT OF THE
ORGANIZATIONAL STRATEGY IS TO IS
TO CALL FOR THIS PROBLEM OF
RESERVE.
BUT I DO WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
WHAT HASN'T REALLY BEEN ON THE
TABLE IN THE CONVERSATION IS THE
OTHER FUNDS.
THE FEDERAL SHARE REALIGNMENT
THE NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT IN
THE TWENTY TWELVE REALIGNMENT
RIGHT BECAUSE IT CAN IN IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE
FOR.
MITIGATING DOWNTURNS IN THE
ECONOMY RIGHT AND SO WE WERE SO
FOCUSED ON THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS THE MHSAA MUCH
OF THEM AS A RESERVE BE. IT AND
SO YOU KNOW I I WANT TO PUT ON
THE TABLE WHAT IS PRUDENT IF
YOU'RE EXPECTING THE MHS SAY TO
TO CUSHION A DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY NOT JUST FOR THE IMAGE
TO SAY BUT ALSO REALIGNMENT ONE
REALIGNMENT TO. AND AND THAT'S
YOUR ABILITY TO DROUGHT ON
FEDERAL MONEY SO IS IT SO. NINTH
I THINK THE CONVERSATION NEEDS
TO BE FLESHED OUT A BIT MORE IN
TERMS OF THE LARGER PART OF
FUNDS THESE ROUGHLY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH NOT
JUST THE TWO. THAT IS MHSAA AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THE WAY IN WHICH
THE FUNDING FUNDING IS USED.
IT'S RARELY THAT THIS PROGRAM
ISN'T MUCH TO SAY FUNDED AND
THESE ONES ARE NOT.
TYPICALLY IT'S THESE OF THE
DOLLARS AND AS YOU HEARD MANY
THE COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
SAY. I'M YOU KNOW WHAT CAN I
BUILD FOR AND THAT THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO OFFER VERSES WHAT PEOPLE
NEED.
AND HAD A WIDE AND HOW THE WHITE
DESIGN MY SYSTEM TO RESPOND TO
PEOPLE'S NEEDS ARE AND THEN
FULLY LEVERAGE ALL OF THE
FUNDING STREAMS IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THAT NEED BASED
STRATEGY.
WHEN.
I MEAN.
TOBY SAID IT REALLY WELL I THINK
THE ONLY OTHER THING THAT WE
WOULD SAY IS.
.
YOU KNOW LEGISLATURE'S.
AT LEAST TWO IF NOT THREE TIMES
HAS MODIFIED THE INITIATIVE. SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU.
TO THE CA.GOV SO YOU BUT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO HAVE A
MORE DELIBERATE.
.
DIRECTIVE TO THE COUNTIES ON
EITHER THE USE OF THE FUNDS ARE
THE RESERVE AND THAT IS NOT
OTHERWISE EITHER CONTEMPLATED
CONTEMPLATED OR SPECIFIED BY THE
INITIATIVE. HE WOULD JUST HAVE
TO WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS BY
WHICH THE INITIATIVE WHAT AT YOU
KNOW LAID OUT IN TERMS OF TWO
THIRDS VOTE IN FURTHERANCE OF
THE ACT. I'M SO WERE ALSO ALWAYS
MINDFUL OF YOU KNOW I'M GETTING
BACK TO MY. COMMENTS TO SENATOR
MORLOCK IS.
WE WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T OTHERWISE AND
DECIDED IT THEY ENACT THE ACT
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE.
BE ALLOWED FOR WELL I THINK GO
FIRST OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE US
ARE BELLS.
A HISTORY AND I THINK WE WANT
TRADE RESPECT WHAT THE VOTERS
VOTED FOR.
AT THAT AND I THINK THE OTHER
PART THOUGH IS THAT.
I THINK PART OF RELEASED AND
ANNOUNCED THEIR MORE LIKE ISN'T
HERE AT THE MOMENT.
UP BUT I THINK THAT THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT.
WHEN A COUNTY THE SITES NOT TO
SPEND SOME OF THE MONEY AND PUT
IT AWAY SOMEWHERE IT'S NOT
MISLEAD THE MOST PUBLIC OF
DECISIONS AND NOT MISS A DEFAULT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE MAY NOT JUST BE
PAYING ATTENTION TO IT BUT THEN
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE HAVE THE
RACE. SITUATION WE HAVE NOW
WHERE PEOPLE TURN AROUND SAID
LOOK AT ALL THE MONEY YOU HAVE.
AND I'M LOOKING AROUND THE ROOM
AND HEALTH ISSUES AND WHY ISN'T
BEING SPENT RIGHT. AND.
THAT AND THAT THAT'S THE REASON
FOR TREATING THE REVERSION
PROCESS
AND INITIAL INITIATIVE BECAUSE I
THINK THE AUTHORS WHEN THEY PUT
TOGETHER.
RIGHT BREAK CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT'S BASED ON WHAT THEIR BELL
SAID SO I WASN'T THERE.
BUT I THINK IT DOES PRESENT. A
LARGE CHALLENGE WHEN. BASICALLY
IF YOU HAVE A POT OF MONEY IN
EXCESS OF ON THE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONER SOME.
ISSUES AND I ACTUALLY ARE
COMMISSION I ACTUALLY SAID WE
ACTUALLY HAD A DESIGNATED.
SO AND EVEN THEN PEOPLE STILL
SAID LUCKY SOD THIS MONEY YOU'RE
SITTING ON AND THE PROBLEM IS IS
THAT THE MONEY'S JUST.
SITTING THERE ARE KNOW I KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST SITTING THERE
PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT IT'S NOT.
BEING YELP IF IF THERE ISN'T
LIKE THIS IS THE PLAN WE HALF
FOR THAT RIGHT WE NEED A CERTAIN
AMOUNT BECAUSE WE'RE DOING SOME
CAPITAL THING WE HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT BUT. BASICALLY IT'S
NOT DESIGNATED.
I THINK AND IT STARTS GETTING
OLDER AND OLDER AND THAT'S WHAT
WE HEARD TO ANY GETS HARDER HARD
TO TRACK WHAT'S HAPPENING TO IT.
THEN I THINK YOU LOSE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE AND I THINK THAT'S
THE THING.
SOME OF A SERVE BOTH STRAIGHT UP
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IS
ACT IS AND WHY IT'S FUNDING SO
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A LOSS OF
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE AND.
AND IN THIS ACT AND THAT IT'S
BEEN FOURTEEN YEARS AND.
ISSUES DO COME UP ABOUT AND WHEN
PEOPLE GO WILL LOOK THIS MONEY.
IT'S NOT BEING SPENT IT WE HAVE
THESE NEEDS WARY SITTING OUT
FOR.
THAT.
THINK YOU.
AYE AT SIT ON THE.
HEALTH AND HUMAN HELP SOMEONE
COMMITTEE AND.
WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH MANY
HEARINGS AND THIS IS THE SAME
THING I KEEP HEARING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN IF IT'S NOT ONE.
DEPARTMENT IT'S ARE NOT ONE.
ACT THAT'S ANOTHER ACT AND IT'S
JUST REALLY FRUSTRATING FOR ME
TO SEE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE COMMENTS LIKE
WE'RE NOT MISUSING THE MONEY NOT
USING THE MONEY IS JUST AS BAD
AS MISUSING THE MONEY IN MY
OPINION BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE.
AND I SAID IT DIE LAST WEEK AND
MAYBE SOME OF YOU OUT WHERE
THEY'RE AT THE US SUB ONE
MEETING.
WE CAN DISPUTE THE THE
AUDITOR'S
A. REPORT WE CAN DISAGREE WITH
THAT BUT THE OF THE FACT THAT
NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT THE FOLKS
THAT ARE BEING ARE NOT BEING
SERVICED THAT'S MY FRUSTRATION.
BAD WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
TECHNICALITIES HERE AND THERE
WHERE'S THE HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS
AND I SAID THE LAST WEEK AND.
I'VE BEEN SITTING THROUGH
THROUGH.
TWICE A WEEK COMMITTEE MEETINGS
AND IT'S THE SAME STORY IF IT'S
NOT THIS ISSUE WITH ANOTHER
ISSUE AND IT'S.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT STRATEGIC
PLANS IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE
HAVE A ANY STRATEGIC PLANS FOR
ANYTHING AND THIS IS BASED ON ME
SITTING HERE THIS YEAR AND LAST
YEAR. THE FRUSTRATION AGAIN
COMES FROM THE INABILITY TO SEE
THE HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS.
AGAIN WE CAN DISPUTE THE MONEY
ALL WE WANT BUT THERE IS NO
NOBODY THINKING.
GOD THERE'S PEOPLE DYING.
AND WE'RE NOT HELPING THEM.
MISS USING THE MONEY IS NOT IT'S
NOT.
THE QUESTION IS NOT USING THE
MONEY AND THAT FOR ME IS JUST AS
BAD BECAUSE WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
DYING ON THE STREETS AND THEN WE
SIT HERE AND COMPLAIN. ABOUT.
HOW MANY OF HOMELESS FOLKS WE
HAVE HOW MANY MENTALLY ILL FOLKS
WE HAVE AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND THEN WE
HAVE A POT OF MONEY THAT'S NOT
BEING USED? FOR DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT AND.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE PUBLIC
MISTRUST IT'S THE LEGISLATIVE
MISTRUST TRIED TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU IN THE LAST TWO AND A HALF I
HAVE NO TRUST IN THE
DEPARTMENTS.
BECAUSE I KEEP GETTING
MISINFORMATION I KEEP GETTING.
THE RUNAROUND WHEN I ASK
QUESTIONS AND THEN NOW THAT.
WE HAVE AN AUDIT THEN THERE'S A
DISPUTE WITH THE AUDIT AND SO AT
SOME POINT WHERE THE HUMAN
FACTOR.
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING OR WILL
WE NOT DOING FOR THE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN NEED AN ALLEY
I'M AND ALLEY COUNTY.
I THINK ALL OF US ARE MOST OF
US ARE BUT I I BELONG IN LA
COUNTY AND AND JUST TO WALK DOWN
THE STREET AND SEE FOLKS THAT
ARE SUFFERING AND YET LOOK AT. A
AT A PILE OF MONEY THAT WE HAVE
THAT'S NOT BEING USED FOR THESE
PEOPLE THESE ARE REALIZE THESE
ARE COMMUNITIES ARE BEING
AFFECTED ORANGE COUNTY. AYE HAS
A HUGE HOMELESS PROBLEM AND I
GUARANTEE YOU YES THE COST OF
LIVING IN THE COST OF HOUSING IS
A BIG ISSUE BUT THEM THE. I
VENTURE TO SAY AND I'M SURE
THEIR STATISTICS THAT MORE THAN
HALF OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THE STREETS ARE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE MENTAL ILLNESSES AND WE'RE
NOT ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM AND
WE'VE BEEN SITTING ON THIS MONEY
FOR FOURTEEN YEARS. AS YOU CAN.
TELL I AM FRUSTRATED I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID
BUT I'D THE PART I DON'T AGREE
WITH IS THAT. WERE WORKING ON IT
EVERY SINGLE TIME I ASK A
QUESTION WERE ALWAYS WORKING ON
IT AND WE'RE WE'RE GONNA COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION. AND YET.
THIS HAS BEEN HERE. FOURTEEN
YEARS PERHAPS EATING IN ITS
CHANGED SEVERAL TIMES BY BOTH
PLAN THE STRATEGIC BUT IF YOU
HAVE A STRATEGIC PLAN. NO MATTER
WHAT CHANGES THE PLAN IS IN
PLACE AND YOU CAN ADJUST
TO TO TO. A BASED ON ON ON YOUR
PLAN AND IF WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN
FOR ANYTHING BECAUSE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE WE HAVE A PLAN FOR ANYTHING
ESPECIALLY IN THIS DEPARTMENT
EVERY TIME I ASK A QUESTION. ON
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEONE AROUND
AND SO JUST.
THERE IS NO REAL QUESTION IT'S
JUST A STATEMENT OF FRUSTRATION
AND.
WE KEEP GOING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND I HOPE THAT AT
LEAST IN THIS CASE WITH THE
AUDITOR GIVING THEIR THEIR
OPINION THAT WE FOLLOW THOSE
THOSE QUESTIONS AND. I'M GONNA
BE HERE FOR ANOTHER TEN YEARS
AND THIS ISSUE AND ALL OF THESE
ISSUES ARE NOT GONNA GO AWAY IF
WE DON'T ACTIVELY DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT INSTEAD OF. KICKING THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD OR OR YOU KNOW
BLAMING YOU KNOW WE GOT A TWO
YEARS AGO WE GOT IT THREE YEARS
AGO. THAT'S JUST BLAME NOW AND
THERE IS NO ACTION AND I AM
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I SEE NO
ACTION WHEN I COULD ASK
QUESTIONS IT'S JUST A BUNCH OF
EXCUSES AND I'M TIRED OF IT. I'M
TIRED OF PEOPLE SUFFERING
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT AND SOUL. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE.
YOU KNOW THE COMMITTEE ARE. BE
HEARING AYE. BIDE.
MY SKEPTICAL.
SOUTH SAID THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE SITTING HERE NEXT YEAR WITH
THE SAME ISSUES AND NOTHING HAS
BEEN DONE AND I HOPE IT IS AND
I'M HOPE I'M WRONG. BUT I HOPE
THAT THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE IMPLEMENTED IN THE NEXT YEAR
WE CAN SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE GREAT JOB BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. I DON'T SEE ANY ACTION
SO THANK YOU FOR THE INFORMATION
BUT IT'S JUST ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW A A HEARING OF WHAT
WE'RE NOT DOING CORRECT IN AGAIN
I JUST PLEAD THAT AT SOME POINT
WE HAVE THE HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT DOLLARS
AND CENTS LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT BEING
SERVICED. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AYE I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO I'M A.
LOOKING AT THE SUMMARY OF THE.
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
INDICATING THAT. THE LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES MHSAA
FUNDING RESERVES TOTALED FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AS OF THE END OF FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
WITH.
AN AVERAGE OF BETWEEN A HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR MILLION IN
EXCESS RESERVES.
FOR EACH OF THE LOCAL MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCIES.
AND.
DAWN.
SO I YOU KNOW. I DO NOT HAVE THE
BACKGROUND ON THESE MENTAL
HEALTH.
.
SERVICE ISSUES AS I DO ESSAY
WITH EDUCATION WERE WHERE I SIT
ON THE.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION.
BUT YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE.
PRUE DEL LEVELS OF RESERVE IS
SAYING I KNOW THAT.
THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
HAVE A RESERVE OF THREE PERCENT.
AND.
IN ON THE ARGUMENT THAT.
THAT THEIR MONEY IS THERE TO BE
SPENT FOR THE KIDS HERE AND NOW.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN I DO
THINK.
YOU KNOW. LIKE EVERYONE HERE I.
YOU KNOW SHARE THE ANGUISH OF
SEEING.
THE HOMELESS PERSON SITTING ON
THE BENCH WITH THEIR HANDS THEIR
FACE BURIED IN THEIR HANDS IN A
DESPERATE FOR HELP.
AND I THINK ABOUT THE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT.
THAT ARE NOT BEING SPENT TO HELP
THOSE PEOPLE.
HERE TODAY.
HOME I.
I WANT TO ASK.
.
MS CAN'T THAT.
YOU KNOW THE FLUCTUATIONS AND
THE BUDGET AND IN THE STATE'S
BUDGET.
ARE THE SAME FOUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION AS THEY ARE ON
THE AS THEY ARE FOR.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SEEN
OF THE ENTIRE STATE BUDGET IS
OVERLY RELIANT ON.
THE TOP ONE PERCENT OF.
INCOME EARNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO WERE ALL
SUBJECT TO THEFT FLUCTUATION IS
THERE SOMETHING UNIQUE ABOUT.
THEM UP ABOUT.
THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES
THAT.
.
THAT REQUIRE THIS MUCH HIGHER
RESERVE.
I AM I THINK YOU KNOW SO MY
COMMENTS WERE AND.
PREDICATED ON MY.
HISTORY AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AREA SO.
AYE WORKS I.
WITHIN THE STATE AND THAT BOTH
AGENCY IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THAT THE RECESSION.
GENERAL FUND DEPARTMENTS THAT
ERROR HOLY WRIT.
RELIANT ON GENERAL FUND SUCH AS
OURS.
CERTAINLY.
I I KNOW THAT EDUCATION SUFFERS
WHEN THERE'S A DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY. UNDER THE.
PROP NINETY EIGHT AND THE
GUARANTEE IT IS A MUCH
DIFFERENT.
OF WORLD THAT EDUCATION LIVES
AND THEN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I THINK.
ON I'D I'D LOST TRACK OF HOW
MANY BILLIONS.
THAT WE CUT FROM THE OVERALL
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET
SO I THINK MY COMMENTS.
ARE ALWAYS.
.
HEARKENING BACK TO THE DAYS IN
WHICH WE HAD TO MAKE REALLY
TERRIBLE POLICY DECISIONS.
AROUND SERVICES THAT WE WERE
CUTTING BENEFITS THAT WE WERE
REMOVING RATES THAT WE WERE
REDUCE. ON POPULATIONS THAT WE
WERE NOT.
.
DETERMINING ELIGIBLE FOR
SERVICES AND SO I THINK MY
COMMENTS AND.
.
REALLY SENSITIVITY AROUND THE
VOLATILITY OF THE REVENUES IS
REALLY PREDICATED ON DOT.
BOTH THE HARM.
AND THIS THE WAY THAT THE STATE
HAS REALLY RIGHTED ITSELF IN
TERMS OF ITS FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S QUITE SOMETHING TO SIT IN A
DEPARTMENT. NOW THAT WE SERVE A
THIRD OF THE CALIFORNIANS.
AND MEDI CAL WE OVERSEE YOU
KNOW A SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
BUDGET BUT I THINK WERE ALSO
VERY MINDFUL AND I KNOW.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS AS A
WHOLE THAT THE ECONOMY CHANGES
AND THAT USUALLY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES ON ONE OF THE
FIRST.
AREAS IN WHICH THERE'S BUDGET
REDUCTIONS AND SO I THINK OUR
RESERVE.
ACCOUNTS ARE ARE RESERVE
RECOMMENDATION AND WHY IT'S
DIFFERENT.
WE WERE TO TRYING TO ACCOUNT
FOR BOTH EXPENDITURES IN
INFLATION.
IN WHICH I'M NOT SURE
NECESSARILY THAT THAT WAS.
EITHER CONTEMPLATED OR ARE PART
OF THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION
I THINK ALSO AND I WANTED TO
MAKE A FINE POINT.
.
THIS IS NOT WERE NOT SEEN SIXTY
FOUR TO EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT OR
WHATEVER THE SIXTY TO EIGHTY
PERCENT. THAT'S NOT ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS THAT YOU CAN SET THAT
ABOUT A SITE IT IS A CAPS.
RESERVE RIGHT SO LIKE IN
EDUCATION
RIGHT SIDES WANTED TO MAKE SURE
BECAUSE I THINK.
SENATOR BILL WAS KIND OF GOING
DOWN IT MADE IT SOUND LIKE YOU
COULD TAKE YOU KNOW THIRTY THREE
PERCENT SET ASIDE AND THEN TAKE
THE NEXT THIRTY THREE PERCENT
SET ASIDE AND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
ARE PROPOSING WHERE ST. USUAL
HAVE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIXTY SIX
AND EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT OF YOUR
ANNUAL ALLOCATION SET ASIDE AS
YOUR MOCKS.
PRUDENT RESERVE AND TRYING TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT THAT
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT EXPENDITURES
FOR SERVICES AS WELL AS
INFLATION.
SO THAT WAS THAT WAS HOW WE CAME
TO THAT NUMBER.
STILL YET A MAIN EXPENSE
EXPENDITURES INFLATION AMEND
THOSE APPLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ALSO AND SO I I FAILED TO.
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES?
AS A AS AS COMPARED TO TWO
SCHOOLS AMENDED.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT?
IT'S
BETTER.
TO TO TO NOT PROVIDE SERVICES
WITH THE DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE HERE TODAY. RATHER
THAN RISK HAVING TO CUT IT OFF
NEXT YEAR OR OR AND IN IN IN IN
TIMES OF A BUDGET DOWNTURN.
AND AYE I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
I IT SEEMS TO ME THAT. THE DAY
THAT DESPERATE NEED IS HERE AND
NOW AND I UNDERSTAND WHY. WE'RE
NOT.
SPENDING THAT MONEY NOW.
.
I DON'T THINK I KNOW IT THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE SAYING
THAT WE WANT THE COUNTIES TO SIT
AND NOT SPEND THE MONEY I THINK
THAT WE.
A AS I KIND OF MENTION IN THE
TOP OF MY COMMENTS SAID THE
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THAT
ALLOCATION FOR THAT'S THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
THE COUNTIES ARE SPENDING THAT
YES SO WHERE WORD WE'RE LOOKING
AT FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'RE NOT
SPENT.
ACROSS THE FIFTY SIX COUNTIES
YES
WELL WITH AN AVERAGE OF.
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION.
FOR EACH LOCAL AGENCY.
SO ANYWAY.
I'D.
HAD A.
QUICK CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR.
BELL AND.
I AGREE THAT.
THIS ISSUE OF.
RESERVES
AS PERHAPS SOMETHING THAT THE
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO STEP
INTO.
TO.
.
INTERVENE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
PANEL.
.
I WOULD LIKE TO.
OPEN THE MIKE FOR A PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
.
ASKS THAT.
ANNUAL WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS
SURE TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO.
.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE RUNNING OUT
OF TIME.
TO A MINUTE.
.
APPRECIATE IT.
I AM CHOI THORESEN I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
ALSO ONE OF THE AND. I THINK
ALONG NUYS WOULD YOU SAY OF THE
MHSAA ACT ARM AND I'M ALSO
CONSUMER. OF THE MENTAL AND AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
NOT ONLY HAVE THEY.
CHANGED EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT
IMAGES SAY WAS ABOUT WHICH WAS
TO SERVE THE SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL BUT NOW THEY'VE CHANGED. THE
WORDING IS THEY'VE HIDDEN AND
NOW THERE'S ALL THIS MONEY WHICH
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX.
MY QUESTION IS TO YOU MY ILLNESS
IS NOT A BEHAVIOR.
BUT I HAVE BEHAVIORS THAT NEED
TO CHANGE.
THROUGH MY MEDICATIONS THROUGH
MY THERAPY THROUGH THE THE
PROGRAM THAT SAVED MY LIFE I
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY WITH A
LITTLE.
BUT I DO WANT TO SEE THIS MONEY
BEING SPENT. AND I NEEDED AREN'T
YOU KNOW WE DO NOT HAVE BOARDING
CARES ANYMORE ALL OF OUR
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL ARE
EITHER.
THEIR FAMILIES TRYING TO
STRUGGLE TO WHERE TO PUT HIM.
TO THEM BEING HOMELESS
WE NEED SOMETHING TO HAPPEN NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ROB BLAME WITH
THE COUNTY HAVE A HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I'M I WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION WE COULD
MAKE LONGER COMMENTS I'D
APPRECIATE THE ACCOMMODATION.
AND WE SUPPORT THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE
AUDITOR AND ACTUALLY WELCOME THE
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP WITH AN
APARTMENT AND STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP AROUND THE IMAGES
THEY PROGRAMS AND POLICIES. I'M
LIKE IN THE AUDIT SAID ALAMEDA
RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO DID VERY
WELL AND THEY WERE ACTUALLY
FOUND TO HAVE COME.
.
COMPLIED WITH AND I JUST A LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
ALLOCATION OF IMAGE AS A
FUNDING.
ON THAT SHOW THAT REPORT SHOWS
THAT COUNTIES ARE COLLABORATIVE
AND ACHIEVING BEST PRACTICES AND
ARE CONTINUING TO BE COULD START
STEWARDS OF PUBLIC RESOURCES. ON
MY ONE UNDERSCORE WHAT
SUPERVISOR CAN BE SAID EARLIER
THE COUNTIES ARE NOT SITTING ON
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
I'M AB ONE FOURTEEN SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR LAST LEGISLATIVE
SESSION GAVE GUIDANCE TO THE
COUNTIES ON HOW THESE DOLLARS
ACTUALLY COULD BE SPENT PRIOR TO
THAT THIS LEGISLATION PART OF
THAT THAT LEGISLATION THE
COUNTIES CANNOT SPEND THESE
DOLLARS BECAUSE THEY OR LOCKED.
AND.
YOU KNOW LIVE VERY VERSION LAWS
ARE INTACT.
NOW COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY ACTING
PRETTY QUICKLY AND THAT ACTUALLY
STARTED THAT THIRTY DAY PROCESS
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT TO INVEST
THESE DOLLARS NOW THAT THEY'VE
BEEN FREED UP IN FACT OUT.
DOCTOR PANS DISTRICTS ON
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THEIR PLAN HAS
BEEN POSTED SINCE FEBRUARY FIFTH
AND ABOUT THIRTY SIX DAYS AFTER
AB ONE FOURTEEN WHAT WENT INTO
FACT.
SO THE AIR THEIR PLAN WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE MORE IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS IN CRISIS SERVICES
ELDER WELLNESS AND HOMELESSNESS
ARM WE STRONGLY WE ARE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO THE ONLY SEE.
THAT PROVIDE CLEAR GUIDANCE ON
THE APPROVAL PROCESS AT EXPECTS
FOR COUNTY INNOVATION PLANS ON
DATA SHOWS AND IT WAS SAID
EARLIER THAT SIXTY THREE PERCENT
OF THESE FUNDS CURRENTLY
SECRETARY VERSION OUR
INNOVATIONS ARE INNOVATION FUNDS
THAT ARE HAVE FULL OVERSIGHT OF
THE ONLY SEE.
I'M COUNTIES HAVE HAD A HARD
TIME DEVELOPING PROPOSALS
THEY'RE BOTH RESPONSIVE TO WHAT
THEIR COMMUNITY MEMBER SAY IS
NEEDED AND INNOVATIVE. WITH LA
I'M WITH WHAT THE OAC STOPPING
COMMISSION WANT THEIR COUNTIES
TO CONSIDER.
WHY THEY ALWAYS SEE DID RECENTLY
CONVENE AN INNOVATION SUMMIT OR
THE INCUBATOR AS DIRECTED BY THE
SPOKE TO EARLIER? ARMED FOR
COUNTIES AND OTHER IS THE FOCUS
WAS ON THE WAY THE COUNTIES CAN
COME UP WITH IN A VERY MODEST
AND ASK YOU TO WRAP UP.
.
WE APPLAUD THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION CREDIT ACCEPTABLE
AND THE JUST A RESERVE LEVEL AND
FOR THE PRIORITIZE PROGRAM
DOLLARS TO THE STATE'S HIGHEST
PRIORITIES ZUBIATE STAY PROPOSES
EACH COUNTY TO BE REQUIRED. TO
BUT NO MORE THAN FIFTY PERCENT
OF THEIR PRIOR PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS INTO THE PUT A
RESERVE. ON.
WE ARE BACK AT A TIME.
THANK YOU AT AMANDA WALLER.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE T. HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK AND
CO DIRECTOR OF OUT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH. I'M A PROJECT FUNDED BY.
MHSAA I'D TO ENGAGE LGBTQ
STAKEHOLDERS IN.
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
FUNDING DECISIONS ABOUT THE
STATE AND THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AS ADVOCATES WE.
APPLIED THE THE.
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT AND.
CALLS FOR GREATER TRANSPARENCY
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND GREATER LEADERSHIP AT THE
STATE LEVEL I'M DIRECTING HOW
THESE THESE FUNDS SHOULD BE
SPENT.
BUT WE ALSO URGE CAUTION.
.
AS I AS THE STATE IS APPLYING
PRESSURE TO COUNTIES TO.
TO SPEND THESE FUNDS WE'VE SEEN
A GREAT VARIETY YEAR AND THE WAY
THAT COUNTY IS OUR.
ARE AYE ENGAGING IN A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
SOME COUNTIES ARE BEING VERY
PROACTIVE GOING OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND MEETING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S NEEDED. TO ADDRESS THAT
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IN THAT
COUNTY THIS ISN'T THE CASE AT
STATEWIDE AND SO YOU KNOW AS AS
THE STATE IS URGING COUNTIES TO.
.
I TO SPEND THESE FUNDS WE WE
HOPE THAT A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WILL BE A PART OF THAT.
.
AND WE'VE PERSONALLY.
HAVE BEEN HAPPY OVER THE LAST
YEAR TO.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS EARLIER AND.
THE PIII AND INNOVATION.
PLAN PROCESS I THINKS TO SOME
PROACTIVE OUT REACH FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND WE
HOPE TO SEE IT CONTINUE TO MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND JUST TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
CONCRETE EXAMPLE OF AND WHAT WE
ARE SEEING AT A LOCAL LEVEL AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL TWENTY SECONDS
OR LESS I CAN DEFINITELY DO THAT
PROBABLY.
WE HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH.
UP PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION CONTRACTORS IN
CINEMA COUNTY WHO HAVE BEEN TOLD
I JUST IN THE LAST MONTH I FEW
MONTHS THAT THERE WILL BE ACROSS
THE BOARD CUTS.
TO THEIR IP  I.
CONTRACTS IN THEIR FUNDS
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF I
TRANSPARENCY YOUR ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR HOW THIS IS BEING SPENT SO
WE HAVE OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THERE
AT THE STATE LEVEL OF. YOU KNOW
ARE THESE BEING APPROPRIATELY
SPENT ON PIII ARE PROJECTS.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT
RESERVE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL I'M
THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING SO MUCH
ABOUT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO I'M
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
STATE TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE PLUSHIE
WALKER LGBTQ PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR NOR CAL MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA AND CO DIRECTOR WITH
AMANDA WALLER OF OUT FOR A
MENTAL HEALTH. I'D LIKE TO
PIGGYBACK ON SOME OF MY CO
DIRECTORS I'M COMMENTS
WE HAVE A CONCERN THAT THE NEED
TO SPEND INNOVATION DOLLARS IS
HIJACKING THE COMMUNITY PLANNING
PROCESS.
WE'RE SEEING COUNTY AFTER COUNTY
THROW MILLIONS OF INNOVATION
DOLLARS AT A SORT OF PRE MADE
TECHNOLOGY SUITE THAT DID NOT
COME FROM A GRASSROOTS NEED.
RATHER RATHER THAN FIND
COMMUNITY DEFINED AND COMMUNITY
NEEDED PROGRAMS.
WE WOULD PREFER TO SEE MONEY
REVERTS AND USED AS MHSAA WAS
INTENDED WITH A REAL AND
MEANINGFUL CONSUMER COMMUNITY
AND STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
COUNTIES HAVE UNIQUE AND
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND WE GROW
VERY CONCERNED WHEN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES ADOPTED THE VERY SAME
EXACT INNOVATION PLAN.
ALSO AS JUST AS AN ADVOCATE.
FOR NOR CAL MHA FOR THE PAST
TEN YEARS I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ECHO A COMMENT MADE EARLIER THAT
WE MAY HAVE A NEED FOR A STATE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
CURRENTLY MHSAA IS SPLIT OVER
THREE STATE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
MHS รณ WE SEE. AND I BELIEVE
MANY OF THE CHALLENGES YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY ARE CAUSED OR
EXACERBATED BY THE LACK OF ONE
MENTAL HEALTH FOCUS STATE AGENCY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ANDREA CROAK
THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY FOR
ACCESS CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
CLIENT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FUNDED THROUGH THE MHS OAC. WE
TOO ARE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND
I WE ARE GOING TO BE SEEKING TO
WORK WITH THE AWAY SEE. AROUND
SOME.
LEGISLATIVE FIXES THAT SH I
WILL COST THE COUNTIES IN STATE
A LITTLETON I'M OUR BIG CONCERN
IS AROUND A ROBUST MEANINGFUL
CLIENT DRIVEN STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS. ON AND WE FEEL THAT WE
WE'RE WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT.
I JUST ONE ECHO THE SENATE SO
HE SAID THAT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE NEED
LEGISLATIVE FIXES.
ALL WE NEED IS LEADERSHIP AND I
I TEND TO AGREE WITH THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING. SO.
A RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE AS A
REQUIREMENT THAT EACH COUNTIES
MHSAA COMMUNITY PROGRAM PLANNING
PROCESS OUR CREATED UNDER THE
RAGS. BE SUBJECT TO THE BROWN
ACT AND COMPLY WITH ALL OPEN
MEETING LAWS BOMB AND A COUPLE
OTHER WE THINK SIMPLE FIXES SO
OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME'S
JOHN GARY I'M THE ASSISTANT
ADVOCACY DIRECTOR AT NOR CAL
MOUTH AMERICA.
I ADD UP TO A I JUST TOLD
WORKING A LIKE A YEAR AGO AND
BEFORE THAT PART OF THAT. I WAS
ON MEDI CAL AND RECEIVING A.
EMERGENCY SERVICES THROUGH STAFF
OF COUNTY AND SANTA SO I HAVE
BEEN ON BOTH ENDS OF THE
SPECTRUM WITH IT WOULDN'T COME
TO THAT.
AND IT DID THOUGH SERVICES DID
SAVE MY LIFE.
I AM CONSUMER AND FAMILY MEMBER
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ADAM.
THE REASON I'M HERE TODAY IS
BECAUSE I.
I WOULD READ THE DH IS IT
DEVIATES.
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
REPORT ON IT AND I DO CONCUR
WITH ALL OF THE STATE AUDITOR'S
FINDINGS.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE KNOWN FOR YEARS BUT THAT
FINALLY THAN IN A REPORT WHERE
PEOPLE TO SAY HEY ALEC IT'S THIS
IS REALLY. ON WHAT'S GOING ON UP
WITH BUT IN WITHIN OUR MENTAL
HEALTH WORLD IT'S BEEN KNOWN
THESE THAT THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN OUT AND.
THE CLUES I COME TO IT I OVERSEE
TO MY JOB A NETWORK OF ADVOCATES
CONSUMER ADVOCATES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS PHONE DISCUSS WITH
THEM FACE TO FACE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS AUDIT. AND OUR
CONCLUSION THAT COME THAT YOU
THE DEPARTMENT OF CARE SERVICES
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH.
OR DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO
MANAGE IT.
SO MAYBE IT'S TIME WE LOOKED IT
UP FOR ME A NEW MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT
THE COULD FOCUS HIS FELLOW.
SOLELY FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND AND AND THE IMAGES
SAY AND ALSO AT THE OTHER END WE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE. INVOLVED IN
EVERY PROCESS OF THE DEVELOPMENT
AND PLANNING AND EVALUATION OF
AVE WHICH IS THE PROGRAMS
WRITTEN IN THE IMAGE OF SAY LAW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT. CONCLUDES OUR HEARING.
THANK YOU ALL FOR.
FOR ATTENDING THANK YOU IN
PARTICULAR TO THOSE THAT
TESTIFIED.
TODAY AT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED